okay let's make sure this is working
um
let's see
okay i'm just going to make sure this is
on
okay so um
okay cool it's working
okay so i'm gonna be honest i'm a little
bit confused as to what
is going on in the manosphere with fresh
and fit and avant-preach
oh no my dad's call hold on my dad's
calling me hold on hold on
hey dad
oh gosh
hannah
i showed you my other phone to call me
on that one
yeah i said it's hannah
what do you mean
i don't think it is because it's on um
it's on wi-fi
it's through whatsapp
i mean it's fine we can just go in here
it's just like this phone i don't always
have
what this one i just don't always yeah i
know i know i just i don't always have
this phone i mean it's fine
thanksgiving nothing i'm in the uk they
don't have thanksgiving here
like nothing
what am i supposed to do i don't have
family in the uk
if we want but i just i don't care
enough like i don't feel like it
what am i up to
um
yeah school practice in youtube i'm
actually on a live stream right now
you sure i mean they can wait
okay are you free in like an hour
okay okay i'll talk to you later love
you
i don't care what i'm doing i will
always drop everything to answer my dad
i love my dad
um
okay sorry guys
for the wait
um
fresh has been caught something
so i'm a little out of touch with the
manosphere i've been moving to london um
i hopped on a live stream
last night
and
i
i i kind of got like a rough overview of
what was going on but i'm not 100 sure
so
so um let me know in the chat what
videos i need to watch so i'm gonna
start
with this one which is abba and preach
and i think that's like what started
everything but let me know in the chat
if i'm wrong
and also how does the audio sound can i
get a good in the chat or
not good just let me know so i can fix
it so i don't do a whole live stream
with no
audio
you guys can hear me okay just put a yes
in the chat if you can hear me okay
um good
and then also i'm going to click the
little bit of the video and then stop it
really quick let me know if you can hear
the video
today's topic um
how do i start this
what's this what what why why the
hesitation
twin sisters
[Laughter]
okay thank you and before anybody gets
upset be like oh you guys really wanted
us to give them like a courtesy that's
the least we could have done before we
do a video uh [ __ ] on them so i
messaged walter and i let him know i'm
like hey man i just wanted to give your
courtesy heads up that we're going to
cover you simply for a sugar baby so i
did let him know before we did a video
on them
oh my god you can hear the video okay i
thought this was going to say can't
you can hear the v let me just double
check
i swear i always
hold up see we learn we grow we get
better
so i'm going to say this before this
whole thing starts
too much
i personally do not care who anybody
dates me it's just like the need to lie
to your fans the need to be a hypocrite
about your own ideals and so i'm gonna
just play the video and you guys can see
what unfolded i'm gonna just give you
guys a quick summary so you guys
understand where we're at all right
fresh prince ceo all right the big fraud
he himself claims that he's fall in love
with the woman or he's really gotten
into her and that she's into him for him
these academics came on the podcast said
hey bro that girl's not into you for you
you said something on like last show
when i was on it was a little bit
alarming
i have to be careful what they want me
for that being said this shorty here bro
listen listen listen that's what either
wrote want me for me 100
all right
you said she was very different from
every girl you meet in miami when i've
heard you speak about every girl in
miami before you generalize i'm not even
gonna lie is this is i've seen a little
bit of this so this is the girl that
he's simping for or like allegedly
simping for no that being said when i
met her i saw she hadn't maintained it
yet she had been like in certain circles
were like you know what damn she's going
through the streets if he says that
being said one more time
if he says that being said one more time
i think i i get what you're saying
i think i'm gonna have to but you know
that being said let's just let olivia
play okay what does it mean
that she's different than not thinking
like a miami girl i just pointed you out
to someone okay like
explain that because i've heard you say
yeah so for example right
this girl is sipping beat
this girl is sitting yes please explain
yes explain go ahead yeah you wake up if
you watch the interview one of the
funniest parts of seeing all the miami
women being shat on while walters are
like the white girl beside me is very
different that being said she's not into
like designer
going crazy like oh i need to have this
and that it's more like it's a good time
with me okay i don't know why i just got
this random link miami florida let's
look through wait
i'm not even gonna lie she is so pretty
i like have a girl crush on her oh my
gosh i i could i could see it to be
honest wait a second
wait a second
22 still in college
why do you think she she's interested in
you ask her i was gonna say can i answer
this question
um
i feel like the first march day that i
met you having that genuine conversation
on the boat like oh yeah oh on the boat
was it 60 foot long was it 85 foot i
couldn't even tell you
uh see i am a very big personality
person so
if he came up to me and he just came and
was like hey let me get your number
that's a no from me the fact that he
invited me and he's been he invited me
out before yeah and it was just the fact
that me and my roommate were sitting
here no me and my roommate were sitting
at home and i was like wow what are we
going to do tonight and then like at
that moment he texted me and he was like
hey with scooters or get on the yacht
let's talk about it and
he's right i'm not a materialistic
person at all i could be if i wanted to
i don't care about that [ __ ] like my
dream car is a [ __ ] honda civic like
i don't there's nothing about me
materialistic who said he invited you
before why you ain't going before
i was always busy or like i was pregnant
you see what your problem is you think
that because i have clout everyone wants
me for club however for you that's
that's true for me it's not i actually
have game bro right that being said hold
on that being said right bro
your experience right with girls is
tainted because you want to see it for
chloe
okay um this is
quite odd
that
he's gonna be like
is he seriously entertaining her
like is he is this his girlfriend or is
this just a girl he's sleeping with
um
because he's bringing her on the podcast
and he's like
putting her up in front of everybody it
just seems like odd that he would do
that
like with all the stuff he says
um okay i'm gonna keep that roll watch
this for me [ __ ] in this house there's
some [ __ ]
[Music]
yo my cousin
she does this she gets like money from
random people on the internet
and i don't know
i guess i kind of do with like donations
on live streams but she she gets like
something like this where like random
men will send her money
um and
i i've never been able to
put the time into pulling that off
make that pull out game week
yeah
can you explain what's on the screen
her getting cash
that's being said i want to get to know
the real you i don't want to get to know
you
okay so the question now i feel like
okay i i i know the manosphere does not
like i feel like i have to say that
she probably
i i think that's enough evidence to say
gold digger right you can't
really say anything otherwise but the
question is how serious did fresh
actually take her so it's
so so you're so you're essentially
basically proving what they say is wrong
in terms of you don't give a [ __ ] about
a high-value man right
i don't know like that's you don't no so
i care that he has a personality and i
can be around
he's a high value man
no i really don't i did not care about
his chain i did not care about his watch
i don't care that he did it you really
don't care like i'm gonna be honest i
come from
like
i'm well off like i come from money
right like my family's wealthy
i i genuinely don't care you would never
catch me dead on a sugar site like you
would you would never catch me on a
sugar site
so
i just i can't come come to any
conclusion other than she is likely a
gold digger n word catch a charge extra
large and extra hard put this p word
right in your face swipe your nose like
a credit card i saw she hadn't been
tainted yet she had been like and
certain circles were like you know what
damn she's going through the streets
dude she doesn't want clubhouse honestly
she won't do this live stream she's
doing this for me so
i appreciate her for that
i actually have game bro right
dang this is your alpha male dating
coach what it is
well it's inside spit in my mouth look
in my eyes this keyword is wet come take
it dive
better
and personally like i said
i guess
let's just watch never forget this man
has a thousand body counts okay this man
slept with okay i'm sorry guys i know
some of you are diehard fresh and fit
fans
i don't believe you slept with a
thousand girls
i
i just don't
um i also don't care like i genuinely do
not care who he sleeps with
um and i don't even think that's really
relevant to be honest for this
scandal so to speak i feel like the
question is
did he actually take her seriously the
thousand plus women oh my god like
beginning to end
so how we met the honest truth
with no cap
we met on seeking
yeah so we met under
we definitely uh spoke
and then i got instagram
and that was it for like couple months
yeah and we'd be talking for like a
minute we didn't talk for like months
because i didn't really want to meet
people
um for a while i was kind of taking a
break because i had a
interesting like living situation at the
time
so i was not meeting people but we're
talking about
the savagery of women nowadays yeah
last week you were with this dude
this week you're with this dude
i see everything
i'm not going to say no names
but i will say she's here
oh and she's beside fresh
what the [ __ ]
my god buddy she wasn't she wasn't she
was ready to date oh
dude she was ready to go
she wasn't ready to date let's just keep
watching
oh you got something to do with yourself
miranda hey i feel like you're trying to
expose me but like it's you have to like
date around hold on you got to come back
let's normalize playing the bachelorette
in your personal life oh you want to
have a hot girl summer all right [ __ ]
you're going to have a bunch of hot girl
summers by yourself pause pause pause
all of them say no [ __ ] my turn that's
all i'm saying okay next
it's embarrassing for a man to marry a
hoe and try to turn her into a housewife
you know the scary part man fatality if
you actually wait for one of these girls
bro
you take her seriously she can't repair
bond so what happens is you wipe her up
you take her in and she's like hello
hello on her body you know what i'm
saying and at that point what what do
you get a used beat up product
that can't even work properly i didn't
say nothing it's my room
it's not me
it's
in your personal life we do what guys do
and then we get so much [ __ ] for it but
y'all do it and then you're like yo bro
that's savage as [ __ ]
you can't even be
a [ __ ] decent woman and not be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of here bro no you dumb [ __ ]
i'm not [ __ ] insecure i'm very secure
in my goddamn confidence i don't want to
[ __ ] wipe up no hoe all right and i'm
tired of women out here telling dudes
smells like energy smell nick energy
you're insecure you have to carry your
hands
i don't really understand
why like i do not care
who they date so i would never tell a
guy small dick energy or any of that if
he has a preference like i have a
preference for taller guys i'm six foot
i prefer guys taller than me
i i genuinely don't care what their
preference is [ __ ] i'm not going to the
lamborghini dealership with 300 bands
for a lambo with 200 000. and i forgot
to add this so i was on a live stream
last night and i think the main
criticism is like
that they really don't know pickup and
they don't know game as well as they say
they do and like their products aren't
as good as
they say
um
so
i think that is like
why this is such a big deal because if
he's something for like
sorry like a typical miami person then
it like kind of discredits his whole
platform miles on it bro it's [ __ ] i
need you guys to hold these women
accountable too they gotta meet your
metric we don't want hoes okay
you want to be a hoe that's fine but you
got to lay in your [ __ ] bed and sleep
there most guys in reality are not going
to accept you for being a hoe and put a
ring on it it's always going to [ __ ]
bother them okay all of them say now
[ __ ] my turn i don't even subscribe to
this thing this is their ideas these are
these are ideologies by their definition
she is what she is right they consider a
hoe that's the red pill movement that's
them i'm not mad at it
but
nick
myron is [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
we use trigger sites
oh and the other um
the one thing that's interesting about
the manosphere is whenever one creator
criticizes another the whole mannosphere
starts to say it's because
they're jealous of them
um
so let me know in the comments do you
think abba and preach are jealous um to
me it doesn't
really look like jealousy it just seems
like abba and preach don't
like them um that's how i would take it
but let me know in the comments what you
guys think
because
how how else would they criticize them
and it be taken like
as a disagreement of their ideas and not
like we want to be you type energy
right to hit up girls
and we don't pay attention
and
go with them we get it for free
so that being said she told me hey
i was on seeking
and i said ben i go under anyway salted
chicks
we met on seeking
yeah so we met under
we definitely um spoke
and then our instagram she told you she
ain't tell you on a yacht [ __ ]
[ __ ] we want to multiple things out to
the yacht she's like yo i gotta be
honest with you right because i don't
want to mess up anything in the future
most girls that you meet bro are on
something bro didn't i tell you at least
she shortly told me bro like the fact
she told me i was like you know what i
respect that [ __ ] if you if i find out
guys are paying you for to smash
that right there's a is a red flag for
me what the [ __ ] is she doing on there
okay so 100 bro i don't know what she's
doing there that being said hey she
might need some money i don't know
what's going on there bro
was it a red flag when
you found out she's on seeking
arrangements and she decided to come
link with you
only when you were on the yacht
no 100 no bro and miami almost
everything you see that's that's good
looking bro
i thought she was different than all the
other
okay so
this video makes it seem like he is
super invested like this is going to be
his main girlfriend or girl
um
and now
i should probably finish this video hold
on no she's been tainted yet but now
she's doing whatever miami girl is doing
okay let's be honest so my honest to go
through body count bro no cap you ready
for it
it's over a thousand
i'm that serious remember i told you
right i told you about barbados when so
basically guys i'm gonna break it down
for you right
so doing live right now so in barbados
right i can tell you before
there's a whole culture of women coming
from i don't
i know that like they say women
subconsciously like it's more attractive
the more girls that a guy has been with
but to me like that's gross that's
literally disgusting
and two
ah i don't know if i believe that but
three i really don't care like he can
sleep with whoever okay he's coming from
like you know uh italy
because the way you talk about women
especially because you're in miami you
just proved that saying that if she's
here and she's new
those rules don't apply
you don't talk to just a miami audience
you talk to an audience that's literally
all around the world so you're pretty
much telling your audience everything i
tell you
doesn't apply to y'all because you're
not in miami
i thought you were giving universal
rules
hold on we're talking about her
no no i know i know yeah but i'm i'm
talking about how you are saying she
doesn't apply
to many things that you would say about
the normal because not everybody that
follows them are from miami that's my
point this advice doesn't apply to
everybody right because they live in
that place where
you've been in my i mean it's a weird
spot it's gonna warp your view of ladies
right oh yeah they're all on sugar
babies [ __ ] sites they're all just
sunday [ __ ] bruh that's that's what
happens where you live specifically
as far as the whole incident personally
me personally i don't think it's that
big of a deal i don't think it's that
important i do think
it's more evidence of what we already
know about fresh which is one he's a
liar okay he needs he's a fraudulent
person right claims to have this body
count to sell his courses claims to have
met her and then went on dates then
found out she was on the sugar-based
site then when it comes out that she's
on seeking arrangements they actually
live stream where he's like no we met on
seeking like everything is smoking
mirrors right
which is fine
at the end of the day if you want to
sell an image and you gotta lie to do it
do it okay
but as far as um
you yeah you you're definitely simping
yeah
i mean
you guys know and i think we all know
this
if these two guys were hearing this
story from any other man about him being
involved with that woman what would they
call the dude straight up straight up
blue pill beta all the other lame ass
terms that they got once it's one of
them
it's fine
you shouldn't date a girl like that but
you know she bit
and that's what you see a lot of from
red pill coaches they're going to sell
you on all these false ideas right
they'll say never get married oh my gosh
yes
i agree with that a hundred percent the
manosphere
cabs they camped so hard
they they say i would never allow this
this this and this and then half of them
guarantee behind closed doors allow it
never get married half of them are
married yeah yeah half of them are
married they'll tell you marriages are
trapped there's a trap
they get married no one of them even had
the audacious they're like i don't know
i just we just eloped it just happened
what that's just you you spent years who
eloped
do not know who they're talking about
screaming about marriage and how
terrible it is and that you would never
do it and you just happen to get married
what then you're gonna go around call
ladies silly and stupid when they dance
on single ladies by beyonce when she's
married to [ __ ] jay-z but look at you
doing the same thing that's it man it's
all smoking mirrors
but even the fans know that listen
listen
one thing i can say about the freshly
fit fan base is that they all know
that yeah because whenever you said
something yeah yeah the other comments
like [ __ ] we know you don't get
anything so i'm gonna say they're not
stupid i think they're really there for
the entertainment but i'm like why do
you need to lie to them yeah she ruff
you ask her on multiple dates she never
shows up then you like you'll come on a
yacht and she shows up yeah she's not
materialistic
she's not not it's not regine car is a
civic
and fine dining yeah and fine dining and
getting cash after a bunch of money by
dudes who apparently don't want anything
in return
okay bro
okay so people are saying i saw a
comment through this because i think
like that video is pretty much done
um that said
um
i can't find it but there was a comment
that said oh fresh was trolling abbott
and preach and they fell for it where
where's the evidence of that
um i don't like that could possibly be
it
but
oh wait ellie get get out of my
get out of my bag that's gross
oh my god
um so let me know in the comments does
anyone have the video for that
because i was on their page trying to
find it
um
all right simping or pimping this is the
live stream anyone know the time stamps
for what we're talking about
a couple of stocks but honestly speaking
lebron if you want to get into investing
in stocks he's pretty good what he does
so
give him a shout out i think a mentor is
good no matter what because there's
always going to be someone smarter than
you
and that you can learn from you hate me
now
what do i hate you no surprisingly not
okay we got um top network talk
networking skill here by um
nostalgia sounds so honestly bro for
networking man it's like
i want to say it's like a
my stand on fresh and fit
with this situation is undecided because
i genuinely like
i mean the evidence that i've seen so
far it looks like he was um
it really looks like he he fell for this
girl and she like bamboozled him
um
but i i keep seeing in the comments that
he's like
faking this whole thing and if he did
like that was very well thought out
and
that was a bold move to like fake this
whole thing like
if if that's what happened then
like
damn so i'm trying to watch this video
and see if i think he looks like he's
faking still because in a pattern
because you understand like when you
network with people you have to add
value so no matter what you're doing if
it's like art you're doing like uh
stocks you're doing like
um even freaking um sports
if you want network you have to add
value so figure out what that person
wants and then from there
meet them with value first say hey bro
for example i do vlogs right so my
example here is like let's say i need
editor for my vlogs
miranda will not be gone by new year's
if it's up to miranda there you go
so
um let's say i'm doing vlogs right and
my editing sucks ass but y'all watch
content right
and someone says to me you're fresh i'm
i'm a supporter of your show right and i
definitely like what you're doing
however i see what you can improve here
i can edit your videos for you here's
some examples of what i've done in the
past check it out that right there is
adding value because you know what damn
i need an editor that's real talk you
know what bam
i got you but i'm looking to it and i'm
with my work from there but he added
value first because he saw i needed i
had a need he felt like that gap and he
said you know what i got your mother so
i didn't value that way helps a lot
um there was another super tattoo that
you missed
no
okay no like one of the ones before the
one that you just read oh w2
no no there's no one here
we got um jonathan hope with 10 bucks
says fresh would you consider becoming a
professional gamer you can run people
for cash smart brothers yo funny store
bro i also got a smash right i play i
won two tournaments by myself here in
california um but i lost it okay anyone
know where the time stamps are for like
the
part where they talk about their
relationship this is way too long of a
live live stream
um
just this is
he never claimed her as a girlfriend he
may not have claimed her as an official
girlfriend but
you
you know it's a big deal for him to be
like
putting here like publicly like claiming
her
like bringing her on the show saying how
they met saying she's different like if
if he meant that stuff and this isn't
all just like a troll you know that's a
big deal like for them
um
this asian kid in my third tournament i
gave up he's 16 years old
okay dj academics live
dj
academics
fresh and fit
uh
[Music]
all right
um
yo fresh
hey listen man
fresh i got to talk about this on your
show
[ __ ] just sent me the
send me the files on your girl i was on
your show
and and i was trying to tell you you met
shorty on a yacht
might be spooky
i seen somebody today
i'm gonna be honest with you they've
been sending me this video all day
they've been sending me this video all
day
myron and fresh bring the women they're
smashing onto the show all the time
okay
um okay person i mean i haven't watched
their content like since i went on their
show really so i don't really keep up
with all of that
um myron and fresh bring women out there
smashing on the show all the time it
just seems like based on the content
that i've seen that
like he really liked her
um
like i've never seen him like put one
girl like on a live stream say that
she's special say how say how he met her
and all that stuff like that's different
than he's done before heading into but
because you want to protect your griff
because you weren't sure i've seen
miranda's pro hello okay let's look at
how yesterday's stream is doing very
nice i haven't gotten ratio yet the
fresh and fit fanboys have yet to arrive
wait why you don't like this who's this
thinking why are you like fresh and fit
that's gang with me
i [ __ ] with them
a comment from playing with fire i'm a
hundred percent sure i've seen miranda's
profile on seeking i even exchanged
numbers with her and the conversation
went sexual quite quick
not a superficial miami girl at all
interesting well i'm gonna have to like
that a heart that and pin that
uh playing with fire they're legit dudes
so
i'm quite positive there's something to
this but i need evidence you know i
can't really just say anything about it
unless
wait a second i just got a notification
on facebook uh
oh from a loyal
subscriber
there's a link to members.seeking.com
let me click over to that
okay i don't know why
what's seeking.com
uh is this i cannot go i'm gonna twitch
you like can i go to it
let me let me maximize this a little bit
let's
what the [ __ ] i just got this random
link let's see who this girl is i mean
she looks pretty good
her name's d milfie
kind of a sus name 23 female
miami florida okay
let's look through wait
wait a second
wait a second
wait a second
wait just a second
wait a second i'm not gonna lie i have
such a girl crush on this girl she is so
pretty
like i wish oh my gosh i wish i looked
like that she is so pretty
non-smoker let me just say this now i
believe that
this
this only um i think fresh set this up
i think fresh probably planted this
there
this is probably in no way it can be
real i think fresh planted this there
100
has to be
social drinker
5 8
22 still in college
[Music]
what the
very open-minded always down to try
something new and embrace new
experiences
personality is key
see i
am a very big personality person
personality personality personality
person
seeking an active lifestyle fine dining
a luxury life let me just say off rip
hey fresh you better be behind this this
is genius well i guess genius
has 2 000 views by this guy but
genius no way this is real lifestyle and
mentorship
oh my freaking
heck
it's miranda
all right hold up hold up hold up before
we move on spank the like button she's
been a naughty naughty girl and show her
who's daddy by subscribing to the
channel
also go ahead and get your free copy of
my book dating is easy that i co-wrote
[ __ ] we're not getting your [ __ ]
butt [ __ ] there are two things that's
happening here okay
either one
you did genuinely meet from friends or
something or you met through instagram i
don't know she happens to have a seeking
arrangements profile
which exposes her she said we got him
he's on the phone
oh [ __ ]
fresh
who is this [ __ ] on my screen
uh one of these ones on top
his [ __ ] name i ain't gonna lie he
hater you hate her you only
yeah i wish i could put you on the
official way but like we don't have to
do it like it's ghetto keep it real
all right bro so this [ __ ] right
whatever me and myra does or do
he wants to pick it and say oh expose
bruh
me and brian i said from day one
we use trigger sights
right to hit up girls
and we don't pay attention
and
go with them we get it for free
so
that being said oh is that the guy that
i went onto his live stream yesterday
is that like coach white pill
i think i went because
last night someone sent me the album
preach video and i just kind of wanted
to see what was going on and i saw like
no someone sent me
the admin preach and his live stream
that's what it was not his live stream
like a video on his channel and instead
of clicking like the channel i was like
i think i'm a bigger like youtuber like
i had more subscribers so i was like i
bet i could join that i just like
clicked on it
and he said i could join and i'm pretty
sure i like didn't recognize him at
first
but
because i think he like shaved his head
or something
anyways i'll i'll continue hold me hey
i was on seeking
and i said bet i go on there anyway
salted chicks and we've been moving this
for like months bro she's like oh i'm a
sports [ __ ]
they tell [ __ ] yo you got some game
you know what you're doing ghost trigger
sights finesse the whole thing cause
remember zola will be a high value and
we politics from there easy peasy look
we got students in australia
canada the states you know ellen's doing
this [ __ ] bro so it's like bruh this
nigga's trying to expose me like bruh
that's just easy dog like it ain't that
serious and she already told me so he
ain't supposed to nothing
wait all right no okay no no what was
she doing on the site i said
by the way and i've listened to martin
explain this
martiji if you ask me so like what do
you explain i'm like i know a lot
yeah i'm sorry guys i don't i only know
one person on a sugar site and that is
my cousin
and she will most definitely use you for
your money i'm gonna be honest like
i always say oh i don't know anyone that
does this stuff i forget i have a cousin
and i always forget i have a cousin that
does um
and if a girl is on a sugar site like
she is
i feel like that's common sense she's
very much interested in your money like
duh that's not so good for that if you
don't care and you just you know you
want to use what you got to get the girl
cool
i don't i don't care who you sleep with
so i get him you and whoever else doing
it but what the [ __ ] is she doing on
there
okay so 100 bro i don't know what she's
doing there that being said hey she
might need some money i don't know
what's going on there bro
but the usual excuse for real girls is
oh my friend told me what to say i went
on there that's the usual excuse i don't
know what you're doing on there myself
personally wait she's still on there
nah nah i don't think she's on there
still but i mean she is i don't know but
she's two minutes that's what's on there
i don't know now
all right
well yeah no [ __ ] everybody been
sending me this video like in the last
three hours they've been acting like
it's breaking [ __ ] news [ __ ]
but you know what because the whole
thing we said oh she's uh you use you as
a gold digger
she been told me everything bro i know
i know who saw the phone in front of me
so at least she told you she's using you
hmm
what's going on
she selling [ __ ] on there that's what i
want to know brother
bro from what i know no but that being
said i really don't know i couldn't go
for what she told me
either way was it a red flag when
you found out she's on seeking
arrangements and she decided to come
link with you
only when you were on the yacht
no 100 no bro hey
almost everything you see that's that's
good looking bro it's not sugar site
that's what we say if you're in the
marketplace bro and a girl's coming here
to my damn does that just mean i'm
does that just mean i was not
good-looking enough to you don't know my
cousin
oh i'm not gonna say that never mind
never mind i will not be saying that on
live
okay wait continue
like
a site where she can get conversations
wait wait wait hold on you're done
awesome real [ __ ] everybody i wanna ask
my chat this yo those sugar size the
[ __ ] wave wait are those probably
more than tinder
girls no longer use tinder bumble
whatever they use trigger size you know
what they want a high value man and
guess what it's time to date them
bubbles on tinder because all they want
to do is
because they know our friends girls will
get the [ __ ] for free because they just
cheating there's an app for that [ __ ]
yes you're not a cat right yo yo hold on
yeah i'm gonna ask you
all right
then i i i heard mine break it down but
like i'm i'm wondering like
like you could finesse that [ __ ] like
that
academics i've been doing this for three
years my friend and look
no no no no no no no it's not about
finessing some [ __ ] over there it's
would you take a [ __ ] off of there
serious
yeah oh yeah bro
what
you got to realize
i was listening to mine to talk about i
think he i guess dave he had an account
or something like that and he was
someone and i was like
in in reality that is like a finesse
that's finessa squid games
so if you could win on there that means
you are really good finesse right
but i don't know if i would trust the
other chick
i don't know if i yeah okay what do you
say like i agree with dj academics on
this
like i'm not even watching this um
to determine like
if he's sipping because if this is real
if like what he's saying is true then
like clearly he's something clearly this
is a lapse in judgment the question
really is
is is he telling the truth or is this
just a show for views
i'm gonna i'm gonna keep watching
because the chick got meat on there
though
let's see let's see all right like i saw
you here bo i don't think the game of
i'm getting what i want on the situation
right now and that's it yeah i thought
she was i thought she was from like she
went to um school [ __ ]
like i thought she was out there just
for school i know she was out there
seeking arrangements
huh [ __ ] i thought she was in miami for
school
she left school to come over here
so they gotta do something to pay rent
and if they ain't doing only fans no
he's talking about uh
yo i was watching this video reacting
some some some [ __ ] i wanna he he seems
like he's a hater of y'all so you know
like we won't give him that
but
but it's some dude who told my um he was
like oh
they found the um
freshest girl on a sugar site and i was
like or some seeking sight i don't know
what that is
and
and and freshman explain first of all
let's not give this [ __ ] no shine
because i could tell you don't [ __ ] with
the program already
but yeah but hold on explain y'all got
to break break because i heard you break
it down one time
is that a is that is that a legit method
to get these hope like
how do you finesse the because
the chase on there are finessers
yeah
that's why we we talk about it we say yo
you need to get on those sites the
difference is is that you got to know
what you're doing though because if you
go in there and you're a trick it's just
going to make you a bigger trick so the
reason why you get on those sites is
because you create
basically you have higher perceived
value so the girls come at you
completely different than on tinder or
bumble or any other dating sites but
it's on you to demand a certain level of
respect and you gotta you gotta make
sure you don't compromise your integrity
on those sites because the girls are
gonna come in looking to finesse so you
gotta have your profile set up a certain
way and you gotta message them a certain
way so they don't think you're a trick
i heard you say that and and i actually
believe it just make sure my [ __ ] fresh
don't get lost on there bro
please
please
you're talking about that yeah it's like
20 it's just like 20 uh 19. hold on
[Laughter]
you can have fun with her oh gosh why is
my
so
you can have fun with her so it doesn't
look like he's taking her serious let's
keep listening to this i'll tell you
this act surprisingly bro i know girls
that are doctors that are on there i
know girls that make a lot of money that
are on there yep what's the point
influencers that make money that are on
there and the reason why is because what
the website does
is it allows them to meet men on their
same socioeconomic status but what the
girls purposely do is they make their
profile private and they only message
the guys so girls are lawyers doctors
etc they go on there make their profile
private so that no one else can message
them and then they're the ones that
message the guys like i've met a bunch
of girls bro that are like they weed out
the broke [ __ ]
exactly they're tired of going on tennis
that's another thing that a lot of
people don't know but you only you can
only find that out if your profile is
good and you're attractive then those
girls will message you yeah because they
get money already so they're not on some
desperation they're gonna hit you up
because like hey listen i'm an
entrepreneur too or hey i make money too
blah blah i don't know why they say that
[ __ ] but who cares
they're on there because they're
screening out losers so that's another
little game changer too
yo yo yo yo i might i i'm okay so
that
that one
little clip makes me think that this is
just fun for him
he could just be going back now that
people have like come out and like found
this stuff on the girl
um but like listening to that little
clip right there is making me think that
he isn't taking her seriously um i'm
about to make an account you're minoring
yo yo hey the next time i'm back there
i'm making an account y'all got to help
me navigate we're going to do what was
the date on this so this is november
22nd
and that's so this was two days ago
yo i do don't stream sometime
yo i'm gonna give you my my [ __ ] no no
no no no no no no we're gonna make it
together we're gonna make it you know
we're gonna do a test we're going to do
it this is going to do live we're going
to do a test
like you know uh um type of situation
don't say that no no no no no no no no
no no no no no we don't know what's
going on
yeah and there's a couple bro i'll put
you on there's a couple no no but no but
we're gonna do it for because i've done
it with like the the t1 the t1 like i'll
make myself a profile and then kind of
hold on guys um i wanted to address the
clout chasing um she's trying to eat off
fresh and fit again um yeah that's
actually exactly what i'm doing i felt
like this stream would get a lot of
views
so i did it i don't
like have people see like i'm a content
creator our job is to get views
hits me up i want to see the interaction
on that because i thought that website
was just for like old [ __ ] who just
wanted to donate money
that's that's that's the common
misconception and it is normally how it
goes but if you're on there and you're
like a dude that's on it and you're like
not weird i'm telling you bro it's like
clean up and you can clean up bro
because most guys out there are weird
hey
get out of there
yep i'm not gonna pet you now you're
just in the garbage so if you're on
there and you got money and you're not
weird you're a normal guy bro it's crazy
because the girls come at you correct
when girls meet you on tinder or bumble
or i need these other sites bro there
are some [ __ ] everybody knows it
everybody knows and it's that bang on a
lot and
and their priorities be like [ __ ] up
you know what i mean
it's not in your best interest to go on
tinder you could
you gotta like exceptional pictures and
you gotta put in a little bit more work
because the girls don't know who you are
like that
perceived sense of value guys i need to
get something from the grocery store
next door um
stay on if you want but it closes in
five minutes
i'm sorry i hate to do this again
i'll be back hold on
i wear my keys
so
oh my god why not put my
keys oh my god i'm not gonna make it if
i don't find my keys in like 30 seconds
okay i'll be back guys i'm sorry
it's crazy
this is five minutes
i made it to the grocery store and back
five
minutes
did i do it to get candy
maybe don't worry about it
okay
i'm back
stop yeah
i can't tell you how many times i
i met a girl on tinder match for her
conversation fizzles out that [ __ ] puts
me back on one of those sugar sites and
then i meet up with her
same picture same profile this is why i
say uh that girl miranda bro she didn't
know what time it was that's what she
came to me all the personality no
whatever what i was going to give to her
yo but does it make you think twice
about her though
if she if she's on a sugar site bro all
right you know what i'm doing bro
come on bro yo yo listen you're fresh i
listen i i'm just not only my brother yo
from island man's island man we can't yo
i gotta make sure you uh
yo yo yo yo yo there's a jamaican saying
this is jamaican sin i'ma just end this
jamaican same
yeah jamaican men
we don't fall in love
we caught up in a love which means you
we don't fall in love we basically stand
up in that [ __ ] you know what i mean
like we're not gonna be delusional to
[ __ ] and
i just gotta make sure
you're always keeping your vision sharp
and that
i'm not about to see my man go out sad
to a chick who might be also selling the
[ __ ] on this on the joint
you get me
did you have that conversation with her
like yo did you [ __ ] no [ __ ] off of
that [ __ ]
yeah i
suppose this is why like bro she told me
how many [ __ ] she [ __ ] over there keep
it real
huh how many [ __ ] she [ __ ] off that
site man
like she meant she met a surgeon
um but he just i think she started
selling pictures or whatever
think she's gonna tell you the truth
like after watching your show
oh
who can find out all the details for you
bro
yeah for real does whatever she's
telling you holy
here's your thing right
girls you think that are sweet and nice
aren't collegeable they're on that site
getting paid for their tuition no i know
so dude it's funny right i'm going to
say i was seeing i'll see girls i worked
at freaking chick-fil-a
down the street i'm like what the what
she's going to say [ __ ]
they're getting dudes paying their rent
oh paying for hair nails it's like bro
yeah
i don't think there's nothing wrong with
this site it's just it's just like these
days for me it's not there's nothing
wrong with a girl doing only things it's
there's only something wrong with if a
girl is doing
only fans and selling [ __ ]
so that's the only thing like i always
got to make sure like yo and what you
doing the only fans oh you on there
sucking other [ __ ] dicks we good oh
you on there like you show a nipple from
time to time you'll be twerking i i
ain't tripping but oh
you're not oh gosh i would
my brother asked me if he should date a
girl that shows her nipple and twerks on
only fans
i would say no
do not oh you using that to [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh i'm good
listen
[ __ ] the only thing you got to know as
a fact
because you don't want you know what's
going to happen now the [ __ ] who she
done [ __ ] up that site gonna jump out
of woodworks
oh yeah i [ __ ] her oh yeah like yo
yeah i met up with her like i gave her
300 bucks to [ __ ] you gonna make you
look crazy
like yo your wifey was [ __ ] for 300
bucks oh that's wow
whatever
do not say that whatever happened before
you
when you gonna be serious with a chick
yo what's good with you now i'm doing
good
you know what y'all doing tonight though
yo why was that show so late tonight
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] hey hey yo yo i'm coming back to
florida in like it was like three weeks
[ __ ]
another movie
another another visit
another movie man yo yo i ain't gonna
lie to you we gotta bring out the yachts
we gotta bring out the jet skis
you know what i mean we gotta do it up
good it's a holiday time
it's time to give it back
i'm ready
this one question she ain't [ __ ] no
youtubers or not like these things that
these things that hate you they don't
shame [ __ ] [ __ ] right please tell
me
no no okay okay
okay cool i mean look
[ __ ] hit me up but it would beat it up
i don't i i thought they were lying
yeah i mean i mean bro
that's not her whatever
like i said before i'm getting content
i'm making [ __ ] like
questioning everything like i'm just
having fun with it that being said
um it just might turn so okay
i'm just having fun with it okay
[Music]
this is
hey let me tell you this man the mere
fact that you caught her ass on some
seeking arrangement [ __ ] [ __ ] you gotta
use that against her you gotta be like
yo shorty i don't believe nothing you
[ __ ] say
you gotta like [ __ ] yeah
what she told you from the get-go
yes [ __ ]
from the very beginning bro she told you
she ain't tell you on the yacht [ __ ]
[ __ ] we're gonna multiple things out
today she's like yo i gotta be honest
with you right because i don't want to
mess up anything in the future
bro i thought with honesty
that's
as long as you keep it hey as long as
you keep an eye i'm going to tell you
this you see when
no
but that's that's the only thing i was
saying though she kind of she was
looking like the girl that was off the
scene
like she was looking like the girl that
was yo yo politeness is every man's
dream and i think i think this is really
like this is the goal really for a lot
of dudes is every man dream to get that
good girl that that hasn't been around
the block
that is like kind looks at you like a
king ain't like these other hoes that's
what you want and that will make you
entice you to check out the game
you feel me
but then but then a lot of times
we get a lot of people who beyond the
dope smile
it's all bad
it's so
bad this one's here right most girls do
you meet bro are on something bro
they're gonna tell you
at least she surely told me bro like the
fact she told me i was like but you know
what i respect that [ __ ] and then two
bro i'm sitting right now bro girls you
would never expect on that site bro it's
like it's like a place they can go to
a payroll real quick get a quick bag
yeah but they gotta [ __ ] though they
gotta [ __ ] for that though
um
according to my cousin
who's a little
you know out there um
you you don't always have to
um
but i think she blocks a lot of guys
like pretty early like gets the money
and blocks them no no all the time
what
hey hey hey let me say this that surgeon
should tell you about that [ __ ] did
some surgery on the [ __ ] that's a fact
if
is all right man listen listen as
here's my thing
y'all my [ __ ] i listen
and i keep saying this
and for everybody even watching this
like [ __ ] i only say this to my [ __ ]
because i don't want them to go outside
because of no chick
ever and by the way i'm talking from
experience because i remember at times
when i put certain feelings
you know for certain people and that
[ __ ] ended up putting me on it
embarrassed me
in [ __ ] what i was doing you feel me
like you know and
had me looking stupid when i kept going
back
okay the way that i
i feel like he likes her as a side chick
i feel like he does like certain
qualities about her
but
like as a side chick i think that's
gonna be my general takeaway get me it
is what it is and i own it but
if
what i've learned from my mistakes i try
to you know hopefully somebody can learn
from my [ __ ] and not do the same because
you know what i mean listen
tomorrow or monday we'll talk about it
expose the whole thing herself and then
go from there i'm gonna go live on my
channel
[ __ ] just just
make sure there's no this
you're fresh you're a brave man
as i said you don't want no surprises my
brother
like even this [ __ ]
[ __ ] you should have said this [ __ ]
before
like you should have been said this
yo yo you see these [ __ ] right here
they bottom feeders
like this [ __ ] looking at you like he
don't like you
like he don't like nothing y'all got
going on
like i could tell already because i
started the video and it was like oh the
freshman fifth fanboys they don't even
like which i represent you know i mean
they hate everything about you
you can't let [ __ ] get the one up on
you that's why you gotta just come clean
already and then if anything be like
[ __ ] i said that already like you know
what i mean like myron said yo yeah i
used to work for dhs okay you gonna
mention that i said it already
you gotta just say everything off top
you say everything on top
you don't look the same but [ __ ] i'm as
long as you good man
yes sir
man [ __ ] i i'm about to get over my
stream [ __ ] i've been working [ __ ] i
did a three hour podcast today i know
hey
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] you was with me when i
was at that [ __ ] you know i mean
from there i went
i was building a bunch of stuff for the
studio did a whole podcast three hours
came back here
streamed
my phone just died chat i love y'all and
it's four o'clock and um this was great
great great great entertainment i know
y'all i'm gonna talk about young boy but
i'm about to talk about my bet
okay i have to go get up and make sure i
commission the right edits
for this meezy
okay
um
i feel like he liked her 73.99 based on
that like as a side check that was my
takeaway
but what is there any other videos i
should see
we're good
that video was filmed all right
after
i'm sorry guys i just had i had a i have
a sweet tooth
after the original
right that was this was before the album
preach stuff right
um
oh my god
this is gummy the other thing
that i feel like the manosphere doesn't
like
they're like oh these hoes will never
get wiped up and in my experience
oh my gosh the manuscript's gonna kill
me for saying this but i was genuinely
thinking about this concept the last
couple of days
and here you have to understand my
experience so my experience
is
oh my face is off um
my experience is i come from a sports
background so when you come from a
sports background
you you get to like deal with a lot of
different types of girls like
a lot of different types of girls and
from all different backgrounds
so
oh someone gave me a new video okay
and you really like i'm not even gonna
lie there's been multiple
um
like like i don't even know like
sleepovers or like hangouts or whatever
where everybody every girl says their
body count like on a team
and
um
the one from yesterday king academics
okay
and
always coming here
the people that had higher body counts
i hate to say it tended to have more
boyfriends
and more proposals
so
oh my god i
i don't like this fact like i don't like
thinking about this because
like when i think about it logically
like this isn't how the world should
work but when i genuinely like think
about it
the the more loose the friend
from what i've seen like the more
proposals long-term commitments like
that she's gotten
so
ew and you you're i know you're like
you're probably thinking oh this is by
low quality guys
blue pill whatever
you you would be surprised like not
particularly
so
take take that do with that information
what you
what you may
um
but
yeah that's like
like that's why i say people cap about
what they will and won't accept
because on the internet it's easier to
say oh i would never accept that that
bad or that
but as a girl you really see the other
side of women
behind closed doors
um
and i have a theory
this isn't hard to believe okay um and i
have a theory as to why
okay
you guys
and the end of the day dating is a
numbers game like we want to say it's
all about like rank
um but there's like you know how
attractive the girl is how fit the girl
is and like that's how we rank each
other and how
you know rich the guy is tall good look
like whatev whatever guys
need
but
my theory
is that in the old days like the guy had
to court you and then
you would be like in a relationship and
then you'd have sex but now like sex
tends to come before
the dates and before marriage
so
because of that it would seem like the
girls that sleep with more guys have
more opportunities to find someone
they're like compatible with
um
because like you guys taking a girl on
the on a date
is like
taking a shot at getting a girlfriend or
getting you know wife whatever you want
or maybe just a one-night stand
a girl having sex is like her getting a
shot at a relationship
nowadays i mean actually i was dating my
boyfriend before we slept together but
that's not the norm and i've asked like
a lot of people this question like what
comes first sex or love
and i would say 80 of the time when i
ask that question
sex comes before love
so if a girl wants to be in love and get
that long-term commitment like a lot of
times the more people she sleeps with
the more opportunities she has
to get that long-term commitment and
i don't like that the world is this way
like that
um
i didn't i didn't enjoy that but i can
say i lost my virginity like later in
life like i was probably the last one
out of my friend group
to lose my virginity
and
i felt like i got bypassed a lot because
i was a virgin and like i didn't want to
sleep with those guys
so
that's just my
personal experience okay
um
sex men love having sex with hoes
again i that idea in theory in theory
works for me like they love having sex
with them they're not gonna wife them
but from
from what i've seen
i i don't i don't know if that's the
case
um
304s get wiped up but not to the guy
they actually want then after a couple
kids 10 years down the road she divorces
him and goes back on the carousel using
his child support
um and alimony okay and again i i see a
different side of women than you guys
see
i i've been on athletic teams so it's a
very particular set of women right
and the women that like i know honestly
didn't have time to go crazy with the
host stuff like
the hoes that you guys think about are
probably girls that have like 50 plus
bodies i i've never met anyone even
close to that number that that admitted
it to me right they could lie to me too
right
but
but
even
even the girls like
i i would say like if i had to put like
line up all the girls i played coll
volleyball within college and line them
up for lowest body count to highest body
count
i would say that the girls that have the
higher body counts like more of them are
married and i would say they're a higher
quality they're all married to guys i
would say above them looks wise and
money
money-wise
so
maybe it's not the top five or ten
percent that you guys are saying but i
would say like
that they got a good deal
so
i
you know i'm not i don't like that fact
i don't enjoy that because honestly
especially like
like throughout college like i was a
like a virgin for most of college so
oh god i don't want to say too much on
live but like
i felt like that like worked against me
to be honest because it was a really
tough sell to be like
look we're not gonna have sex
for this amount of time or for until
we're in a relationship or whatever
and i would see girls just like giving
it up
and they would get like that
relationship and i'm like
huh
so
okay wait where am i going
um
you're young i'm coming from the
experience of 50-plus years two
marriages and multiple women well you're
coming from the experience of like
the guy on the losing end i hate to say
it but like you can't be on the winning
end
with two failed marriages
um
please please stop calling these guys
high value well how do you know you have
no idea what guys i'm talking about
so you have no idea if they're high
value or low value to be honest um
okay wait what video am i even watching
i forgot
is it this one um
well
it makes sense that their husbands look
better and higher economically and
that's what women want right
so
who's the real winner
like
i'm telling you
the most single like girls i know
that
are like
eternally single
have only slept with like two three guys
and are in their late twenties
the first one okay
and guys i don't i don't enjoy this i
don't i don't like this
it's just an observation that i've had
also we have to go into like what you
would define as a hoe
i get very like
mixed and varying things about like what
you would define as a home
okay
is it because
sorry
this caramel is like too chewy i need to
stop eating it um
is it because the eternally single women
have high standards above most women
um i i would say a little bit
maybe partially
but
to me it would seem more like
a lot of those women want the
relationship before the sex
um
that's just like not
i don't want to say it's not how it
works nowadays because i've i've had
that like i've done that but
i would say that's not that's not
standard now
yo boom
i see i see you still in here man
salutes you
boom i'm almost about to
um
tell me there's no instagram
type to this no i think that's not
hold on check my man sorry
i apologize all right
skip this [ __ ]
okay where should i skip to
oh my god this is a two hour stream
oh my god
the only thing with fresh is that
like fresher just text me he said he
said act
i been knew she was
doing that on a sugar site wait hold on
like yo it's it yo it's like boom it's
like you saying yo act i've been you my
[ __ ] was [ __ ] other [ __ ] i'm like
wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait what you know what i mean
45 okay
let's go yo i'm getting off of this man
if y'all [ __ ] know how to if i think
he's know how to make voodoo dolls and
like you know what i mean
in honor of like you know fresh that we
can stick some pins in it that this [ __ ]
did but
other than that yo i got a question what
what's going on with uh angelica
bro
yo where are you
[ __ ] where you at
[ __ ]
where is miranda that's her
the scenic because on your face
you had that face
no no on your face you had that face
like ah shut the [ __ ] up you fumble in
my bag when i was like you know going on
fresh but yo keep it 100.
yo it's the long-term bag like like come
on you're seeking arrangements like yo
only a [ __ ] idiot only a [ __ ]
only a [ __ ] idiot
only a [ __ ] idiot would just give you
the back immediately so like you knew
you had to play the long game no hold up
the only question i'm not here for that
i am not here for that if i wanted
something to give you money i'd want it
now i wouldn't want long term
i can make money
all right okay let me just ask you one
question
i will always stand by that why were you
on seeking arrangements
i know she'll get it because i watched
it on tick tock she got a tutorial to
get it yo miranda you devious i know a
lot of you
i'm not i don't ask for [ __ ] people give
it to me i don't ask for anything [ __ ]
you gave a tutorial to get it
let me know
yo miranda you could never in your life
and that's be like how you finessing
fresh never in life like i'm i'm too
advanced in the game
like that [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
that yeah that [ __ ] yeah
yo that [ __ ] and by the way when i say
finesse
like i'm talking about the long term by
the way i think in your mind you've
committed to being with him
no no you're right you've committed to
being with him for at least a year you
won't see no benefits for at least 12
months you're smart
miranda can i ask you one question
because i've seen a clip
hold up
i've seen i've seen better gold diggers
than you trust me listen let me ask you
one question yo
all i want to know is this
you all
miranda miranda if you're not a gold
digger why the [ __ ] you want seeking
arrangements where young pretty girls
hook up with old [ __ ] with bread
100 with you my mom got three jobs yo
she had three jobs during that time she
was not doing that yo miranda you gotta
just admit
every
club and the second place got a job i
called
every single person that i needed cap
i doubt that cap from one person
yeah completely because i didn't want to
do that because i had an income yeah
miranda miranda
i'm gonna keep it 100 with you
like yo
no no i yo me and you gonna be mad cool
after you finish fresh i'm telling you
this right now because we're gonna have
a good conversation here's the thing
hold on
no trust me no no yeah yo here's the
thing his name
bruh
yo i'm not saying that you didn't have
to go through [ __ ] but but here's the
thing
yo the
the average woman don't think oh how
could i get over on [ __ ] i'm telling
you yo what about her [ __ ] homies
and i did it to survive and the second
that i don't need to do that i
completely stopped
if that [ __ ] didn't say yo pull up to
the yacht you would have never linked to
that [ __ ] in life
i just want you to keep it on it with me
miranda miranda miranda
would you
mirena
would you have went on a date with that
[ __ ] right would you have went on a
date with him
if
okay
you
weren't
i if if if you if he worked at
chick-fil-a
you would have never linked to that
[ __ ]
once you heard that yacht
he can't work at chick-fil-a
i didn't know that i didn't know until
the day
why is she getting so angry
oh my gosh chill lady
yo fresh you trying to say you're fresh
i'm keeping a honey with you
fresh french you're french i don't even
believe that you know why
i read her seeking arrangements profile
[ __ ] she know the car is more than a
car salesman she know yes she know plays
she no jets she know opulence and wealth
[ __ ] she probably could tell you how
much horsepower your car got what do you
know bruh all i'm telling you yo miranda
listen
i actually don't
even know why this is controversial like
she's clearly
using him the question is is he using
her too
oh
yo miranda miranda miranda i'm gonna
keep it 100 with you and it's just cause
i i love fresh i love her that's my guy
cause we both from the islands but i'm
gonna keep it 100 with you
[ __ ] i got all i got listen
this whole day today everybody hit me up
[ __ ] i got a whole [ __ ] from
philadelphia who will break you down
like a kilo coke they say you've been
doing this [ __ ] for five years ago i'm
gonna keep it on it with you keep it on
with you
no no no no not being on the site not
being on the site they said you've been
cloud chasing dick hopping money chasing
doing the same [ __ ] you're doing in
miami but you were doing it in philly
with a bunch of bearded [ __ ] but them
[ __ ] were standing thorough they
wasn't folding like fresh they were
standing thorough you know philly [ __ ]
you know i mean they used to pray for
times like this to round like this to
not get finesse like fresh awesome come
on man stop playing
do you want to see my track record
like none of them are rich
like none of them are like
yo i seen the clip already did you [ __ ]
the niggle the old [ __ ] in the corner
the week before you link refresh
i
stop it you don't got to watch the video
you was there did you [ __ ] the [ __ ] yo
there was a [ __ ] who said yo there's
somebody here who linked with this
right here and then now
they're right here
stop the cap
so you never [ __ ] nobody
[ __ ] that's too much of a coincidence
so how the [ __ ] you meet me
yo i'm gonna keep it a honey with you my
future girl hold on
no my future girl
if i meet my future girl she can't tell
me that the [ __ ] she [ __ ] last week
is also in the room what the [ __ ]
he wasn't in the room he was he was the
old ass [ __ ] you look like 50.
keep it a honey
that was your sugar daddy damn
damn
i have no idea
[ __ ] i got the footage right here i got
it i got it
hold up hold on
yo hold on
stop that cap
hold on
last week you were with this dude
this you're with this dude
i see everything
i'm not gonna say no names
but i will say she's here
oh and she's beside fresh
yeah heard what the [ __ ] said last week
you were with that dude this week you
went this dude
but did you [ __ ] him though did you [ __ ]
him
yo if you [ __ ] the [ __ ] that's in the
same room
if you [ __ ]
what are you holding up yeah you're
the first thing you just said is he
ain't give you [ __ ] you ain't saying you
ain't [ __ ] him you say he ain't give you
[ __ ] which it's kind of like you lean
into the
the guy same
said that is his friend so it wasn't him
he said my boy i know
she pointed at the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] was in the corner he was
looking old and senile the [ __ ] look
like he needed 10 viagra he needed that
it is
[ __ ]
yo yo you're fresh yeah i don't play
dumb bro hold up it's in 4k hold on stop
the cap hold up
oh my gosh i don't know what to think
because this is this is kind of
convincing this is convincing like
this seems really real like this
argument
[ __ ] i know you was there but look like
you haven't looked like you off the
hennessy i'ma pull it up in
hold on look fresh
fresh right here it's right here fresh
fresh it's right here
fresh
look look i'm gonna play it
look i sweep you over with this dude
this week
last week you were with this dude this
week you're with this dude
[Music]
i still don't know who they are
miranda miranda miranda
i'm gonna give you one more chance
so you never
so what that dude said was cap because
that [ __ ] he said he got a whole story
about you hello
the [ __ ] who said last week you are
with that dude this week you're with
that dude
if dean has a whole story on me i don't
[ __ ] think so
no no he said he got a story of you
[ __ ] two [ __ ] back to back in the
same week
[Music]
wait you [ __ ] fresh friend the same
week
[Music]
[Music]
completely understandable i understand
that that happens all the time hold up
yo wait what's this thing you know this
[ __ ] look only see now hold up
i literally still don't i didn't even
know that he was yo but you confirmed
you [ __ ] the two i who was the other
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
so basically right
[Music]
the jamaican guy said yo
fresh just so you know
she smashed my boy before she met you
she said look if she want to talk [ __ ]
on the podcast
okay bro welcome before me i'm gonna
[ __ ] because we're just having fun so
either way open before me i don't care
about bro like for example dude any girl
are you [ __ ] she's [ __ ] somebody
before you no no no fresh fresh french
i'm gonna keep it 100 with you if you
[ __ ] a girl
the same week as me that cannot be my
girlfriend disqualified
disqualified you have been yo
huh
after me yo fresh is a [ __ ] yo you know
wait you don't watch the show
fresh supposed to fall [ __ ]
but listen i had no [ __ ] idea this is
a guy who like i had talked to since may
since may
like he's a random dude that i met and
then i went and [ __ ] we've had
countless conversations like he's a good
dude i still have nothing against this
dude oh it's not like you [ __ ] him again
you tripping girl you tripping maybe not
that long once i'm at fresh i don't i
haven't even spoken to him i don't have
contact with him anymore because i cut
him off wait
[Music]
yo miranda girl i'm gonna lie to you man
yo yo yo yo miranda i'm gonna keep it on
honey with you yo miranda you can't
speak man
miranda i'm gonna keep it on honey with
you
i honestly wish we never met cause your
game would have been so good
but like i'm sorry fresh my [ __ ] i just
can't see him go out like that i just
can't see him like like looking like a
herb like that's my [ __ ]
all right
question for you bro how am i going
outside
will show me
oh my god
fresh
what you mean how you going outside
fresh
she literally
you saying that yo you [ __ ] with her
but she's on seeking arrangements trying
to find the bag she's been [ __ ]
[ __ ] for the bag
now you're with her you're thinking that
she's not trying to look for
the bag come on
come on
you know when it goes
that i [ __ ] wrong with long time it's
like bro for me
oh my god this is so crazy
like
fresh you made her your face card you
made her your face card that's hey hey
i don't know what to believe because
people are saying this is all like
an act like it's fake
i feel like okay if this is fake like if
they're making this up i need to see
like videos of them
talking before
i need to see it otherwise this
there's too much emotion in this
conversation i don't think they're that
good of actors i don't i'm sorry
i think that
i think that if if this is fake i'm
impressed i'm very impressed if this is
like a troll
i don't know you got to let her know
not to be the face guard
she's eliminated
what is a face card is that like a
screen saver you gotta tell the truth
[Music]
she bro
she can be the face card with all it
does she done did she was on seeking
[ __ ] these old wrinkly ass [ __ ] she
[ __ ] another [ __ ] who you might have
some type of ties to same week as you
she can't be wifey she could get some
dick keep it moving keep it rolling but
a high value man like yourself gotta be
bagging the chicks that is inaccessible
through a badass [ __ ]
fresh you have to tell her she's
eliminated from being wifey that's what
you gotta tell her brother
i'm telling you right here
miranda
you are eliminated listen you're one of
the hoes i'm gonna keep it 100 dj
academics it's hilarious too
keep it holly with you
it's cool but like [ __ ] i seen you on
tick tock you know what it is
i thought you were like this nice girl
who didn't know
you know what it is then yo
fresh is a real [ __ ]
high value man you gonna get some pipe
from time to time but to keep it real
you can't be the face card i ain't got a
lot of you can't be the face card my
[ __ ] got a whole brand a reputation he
gotta wear that on his back you got him
looking like a sucker everybody who
bought into the fresh and fit [ __ ] you
got [ __ ] second guessing to him fresh
is a boss he don't got time for your
little petty games they even played on
seeking arrangements you've been [ __ ]
wrinkly ass [ __ ] like this [ __ ] with
glasses bifocals [ __ ] who need like
lasik you can come on now you should to
keep it real
it's like i remember i asked you you
should be honored to share a [ __ ] like
french that's a fact
come on man
what are we doing
i know that fresh is high value we've
talked about it before he can do
whatever why didn't you be honest yo yo
cause you caught him off guard why don't
you tell him about all the past of all
the slimy [ __ ] you were doing
no
so you're telling me that you told him
you was on seeking arrangements
basically
spend time with him he's a genius
he's a genius
he's a marketing genius
yo you was living in your car you living
in this condo now hold up stop it man
you was living your car you just told me
that you living in this condo you
running around in uranus is mclaren you
was living in your car in a [ __ ]
dusty part of miami that [ __ ] got you
in the goddamn
you living in luxury stop it
that's why you got to put the time in
that that that it could pay off
you supposed to invest
the smart girl
yo
this is the difference between you and
brittany renner you play the game wrong
britney renault would have invested her
time she would have wait should have
waited a year or two
he found you out in a month
in a month he already kind of started
[ __ ] with you but then he found out
the truth that can't work
oh my gosh thank you for the donation
i've been i've been strapped on cash so
i appreciate every single donation
i'm gonna i'm gonna stop my live for
that thank you so much okay there do you
feel like there's a difference between
taking a girl on dates and dinner to
have sex with her and directly paying
cash to have sex
yeah um i'm gonna be honest like
logically
i don't know what it is because like
when you think about it like it's kind
of the same thing but like
there's a difference i can't tell you
what it is sorry that's not a good
answer what's the problem
you said that to every [ __ ] you've been
with
keep it on it
what did you say you said that to every
dude you've been with
i
about
yo yo ladies and gentlemen of the jury i
got the tick tocks right here
i don't know his name i still don't know
him no no no no no no no one i don't
even think he's that old
no it's cool it's cool we're not talking
about him anymore we just want to talk
about we want to talk about this is what
we want to talk about right here because
people don't know me
hold on here right here takes 45 cents
from every dollar you make so i really
made like 43
you just go to the my fun tab and then
you can see like how much you make blah
blah blah basically just set up a
profile verify that it's you add some
photos add a basic bio
and then start talking to people
yo you sound like a forex trader yo you
yo come on you you breaking it down
do you realize in that video i said i
didn't even have money for a 36 dollar
parking ticket yes so you were finessing
[ __ ] now you're trying to finish my
[ __ ] friends
[ __ ] look up the site look at the
[ __ ] sight and you'll see that they
literally pay you to talk
me to to them
they have to pay you at least a dollar
yo yo i know a lot of you all right hold
on yo
yo miranda miranda i i'm marina i i
believe you on that i believe in that
yo miranda put it on your life that
oh with all the [ __ ] you was doing you
wasn't [ __ ] none of these [ __ ] just
put it on your life
no bro from that website no i was not
[ __ ] anyone yeah you were [ __ ]
about seeking arrangements that's what
you were doing
and the people i've met from seeking
arrangements gave me nothing except for
one person during covent who i cuddled
after i got a job the other people i've
met
one day you did what
i said during covid that one person that
i talked to during the time of covid
where i literally did not have a choice
because i
had no [ __ ] income because it was
proven you sold a [ __ ] keep it real one
person
who would fly me out
and [ __ ] you hold on we got to call it
what it is he [ __ ] you
we did have sex but that was after we
had talked for two months because we did
not live in the scene just like how you
talk to fresh on the ball for an hour
it's the same [ __ ] let's keep it real it
is not the same [ __ ] it's not the same
[ __ ] sorry that i wanted to like it was
hey we're gonna get to know each other
he
was the same way like he didn't want to
just [ __ ] me like he we were very
separate
he said here's what's going to happen
like we're going to talk for this amount
of time it was coveted almost going
anywhere anyways we didn't live in the
same sea and then finally we were like
okay let's meet whatever we always had
like good conversations and then when i
got here
same thing like i would talk to people
first and then like i would go on a date
with them and if the date went well then
maybe okay we would
but there were times where
it wasn't even like that or it would be
like months and months and these were
people i've dated like multiple times
i've seen multiples
hey i'm gonna be honest with you
yo yo i'm gonna be honest with you i'm
gonna be honest with you it's just cause
like like yo as i said fresh my [ __ ] so
like i ain't trying to wall out
yo i really appreciate that you're
looking out for him yeah i'm gonna keep
it real with you there's a [ __ ] from
philly who got a tape of him donkey
[ __ ] you i'ma keep it a thousand and
he testifying to me saying that yo what
y'all seen she's always been the girl
who just goes to the dude who got
something going on and she [ __ ] on him
until she gets live but that's just
alive and he obviously does not know me
you can look at my track record half of
them are people
that like are in the service industry
that literally have nothing like wait
are you saying he's a liar because i
would like to i don't know what you're
talking about so how can i [ __ ] say
that i don't know what you're talking
about no no but but if if that's the
story is he a liar because if he comes
out with the tape i just i don't condone
he said he's from philly he says he
knows you from like uh um high school
that's what he said he said i know her
from high school she was always like
that me and her [ __ ]
yo she did the same [ __ ] to blah blah
blah like you say some [ __ ] you say
yo i have a tape of us [ __ ] it and i
said i'm good i don't need to see it
but
is he lying if he's lying let me know
i'll call that [ __ ] ass [ __ ] out i
would genuinely love to know who this is
because anyone that i [ __ ] from high
school was
in high school
we could call him a liar
yo yeah hey oh you're mad fat matter of
fact yo
if you don't show the tape you lie
little [ __ ] ass [ __ ] hold up
[Applause]
no no no it's not a view in high school
he said this is this is when you grown
and over 18 because trust me i would not
look at no video of you of you anybody i
don't even see it
he just said he has some video of him
[ __ ] you and he said yo you are
always like that
genuinely don't know who
it is
some light skin [ __ ] from philly
light skinned [ __ ] from philly right
now i'm gonna tell you right now hold on
let me find this [ __ ]
a white skin from philly
skin [ __ ] yeah
yeah
that i went to high school with
i don't know if you went to high school
with you but you said you were like that
in high school hold on i'm fine
person that i [ __ ] from my high school
is literally still to this day my best
friend and like i haven't you [ __ ]
your best
we have not friend
since like junior year like
junior so long ago and we're still
friends only because like we
are not we don't have that type of
relationship i always help him get girls
like
you guys are weird
i've had sex with zero zero of my guy
friends
we don't even really see each other like
we'll facetime each other maybe like
once every six months but he would never
[ __ ] do that [ __ ] to me
[Music]
it was so [ __ ] long ago
and he's not that type of person so he
would not do that to me all right
let me figure out his
name i'm about to like snitch on a [ __ ]
now like come on man you think i'm six
nine all right hold up man hold up man
hold up
holy
holy
hey hey nana
oh
[ __ ] yo hey hey miranda i'm gonna keep
it honey with you
i'm gonna hit you offline about this
we're gonna leave this one alone i'm
gonna this this particular issue but
anyway yeah i just want to make sure i
just want to make sure
[Music]
no i'll tell you offline of course yeah
but wait listen i just want to make sure
you know what i mean you're my man
friend yo my man fresh you're a good guy
he high values
he'll bleep out his name
[ __ ] alive how to hide the [ __ ] we
gonna bleep out his name type of message
you gotta go
i don't give a [ __ ] but i want to know
who it is because that's [ __ ] up
listen [ __ ] what he's saying and you
want to call me a clown that's a [ __ ]
call chaser right there someone who
wants to throw my name under the bus and
say i have a video of her
and that's why we're not even going to
acknowledge anything but anyway listen
sir
what the [ __ ] listen hey listen first of
all first of all first of all i didn't
see no videos second of all if this is
something that you might be on the age i
gotta do it you gotta you gotta get that
[ __ ] back and blow that [ __ ] man i know
a lot of you please because it's me and
i don't know what it is i don't know who
it is
why do you think people are hating on
you when you're fresh though keep it
real
because they will obviously like
people don't want to see people happy
like no one knows
mine and fresh's relationship like
outside of what they see online like
there is a whole different
aspect to this than what everyone else
sees so okay on the outside maybe
whatever i look like a gold digger i do
not care like when we are alone
every time i've seen you i look sweet
together i know a lot of tick tock [ __ ]
threw me off and a secret arrangement
should do me off i and that's why i did
not ever think that i was going to come
by someone like fresh again that i was
going to genuinely like and want to
spend my time all right okay could you
admit though could you admit though
[ __ ] everyone like i don't give a [ __ ] i
didn't even talk to my family in those
phases because of issues that we've had
with money because i like was so mad at
my parents that i ever had to do that
[ __ ] so i didn't talk to my parents
why your parents got you doing that you
white
that was funny that was funny my parents
don't have [ __ ] money like you don't
understand there's like wait you
caucasian right
it doesn't [ __ ] matter like my family
does not have money like they still
don't have money i still don't get
anything from my parents
also if you guys have been here for over
30 minutes and you like the stream
send a super chat you know i do this
stuff
out of the kindness of my heart
but also for money so
yeah i'm just i'm gonna throw that out
there you don't have to
do what you like
no no no no no i understand they're not
honestly not not everybody's well off
and [ __ ] like that yeah yeah
i guess i guess the point i was asking
is like yo
huh
what do you mean she going she jumped
out the car
yeah
hi all right later
man holy
[ __ ] bruh
yo fresh
listen man
hey yo fresh
check your pockets right now
um okay my dad is not a billionaire
but yeah he's pretty he's pretty rich
i'm not even gonna lie to you
um
but unfortunately
he has told me that i am too old to be
sent money
so
i'm sure if i was like homeless the man
would help me out he's not nasty you
know but
your girl's just trying to work out here
let me live
i forgot all my cash i forgot everything
bro how much did you charge on the car
tonight on the master card
wait they unfollowed each other on
instagram okay let's let's check that
out
[Music]
instagram
um sure except all continuous just
pearly things
um
okay i'm gonna watch this while that
logs in
damn
hey man here's what it is bro yo fresh
i'm gonna keep it honey with you
and no no this is a real question i'm
gonna be honest with you
you're not mad at me right like ah like
because you're fresh i'm gonna be honest
with you i feel like you love her and
you don't want these questions to be
asked but i [ __ ] with you i can't i
can't have no chick finessing you like
that bro
if i was bothered i wouldn't even pick
up the phone to call you secretly
like if i really care that much bro
bro i don't really care bro so anyway so
keep it real so keep it real
you thought the same [ __ ] as i you you
these are questions you had too you just
ain't asking yet
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no
that's why i'm like
um ass is a bunch of [ __ ]
okay what's her name miranda
i'm can i not search on this
damn
okay i have to do this on my phone cause
there's no search button
okay so obviously you don't want to set
that camera because it makes you look
more lego
i don't know what she's been through
issues [ __ ]
yo [ __ ] you came from barbados you used
to walk barefooted on the beach trying
to pick up [ __ ] i came from jamaica i
used to work barefooted in the [ __ ]
countryside she's white living in philly
you telling me oh my gosh
so miranda it looks like i don't know
what her instagram is anyone know in the
chat she was broken in us who came over
here on a banana boat and a [ __ ]
illegal immigrant
what oh my gosh
she addressed the situation on tick-tock
live but i don't have tick-tock
okay let me let me look up let me look
it up hold up
she's really broke
bro i get you guys some money now and i
get i got some money but [ __ ] my mama
came over here working three jobs [ __ ]
she came over here not trying to work no
job her first instinct was to finesse
[ __ ] bro please don't be delusional
mom
see they got a handlebar [ __ ] like me i
got to keep it 100. i want to hear that
[ __ ] my mama came over here working
three [ __ ] jobs cleaning [ __ ] off a
[ __ ] that was on his deathbed
that's a fact
not cause i got some money i'm like oh
my god well she didn't have any money
[ __ ] she didn't want to do nothing but
finesse things bruh let's keep it on it
uh
she's broke bro she's broke brother is
that is that username her tick tock or
her instagram because i don't see a tick
tock let me see
she's broke man she's broke man she she
came from nothing
families are struggling yo yo that's how
[ __ ] get you to sympathize with them
bro she literally said that so you
that's where it's literally like my
homelessness could give you a sec
let me say this i don't know where fresh
came from but wait if a [ __ ] tell you
oh
i'm broke and i had to live in my car
you see if you're really in the hood
you were looking at that [ __ ] and said
[ __ ] how the [ __ ] you even got a car
no you look at that [ __ ] if you're like
tyler perry
she got a car
how the [ __ ] you pulling sympathy for
her [ __ ] she came now okay i just
looked at her instagram um she
definitely unfollowed him and he does
not follow her miami from philly [ __ ]
she didn't want to work for the [ __ ] she
wanted to get
[ __ ] if we told my broke i could tell
you what my mama had to do three [ __ ]
jobs walk a mile to a bus stop she had
no car
this chick she claims she's sleeping in
a car [ __ ] but all she's doing is
[ __ ] [ __ ] who got bread [ __ ] is
y'all [ __ ] talking about
she in that car once a week bro she in
the condo with another six days this is
why i be looking at fresh like dog my
[ __ ]
if you trying to save your reputation
just call it spade and spade early and
say bruh okay what what's today the 25th
the last time she posted on tick tock
this is her right
this is
[Music]
like that seems
so interesting i had no idea and then i
told all my friends this was like whoa
did you guys know that fetty wap only
has one eye
and we're like yeah that's like pretty
much what he's known for
um
yeah she doesn't have anything on here i
don't know if she was like live or
something
uh i don't let me see if randy let me
just see if there's any screen
recordings from her live posted
um
no this is a different girl
um
randy pandy live maybe let's see
let me just do this week
damn nobody screen recorded
give it an excuse cause you look mad
naive and i know you a smart [ __ ] don't
be making excuses for some chick who you
know running game the [ __ ] she talking
about she broke she came to miami [ __ ]
her first instinct wasn't to get any job
there's mad jobs in miami her first
instinct was to get on [ __ ] seeking
arrangements
her first instinct was to get a [ __ ]
who had it not get it on her own [ __ ]
are we talking about
this this is what we talked about
like my [ __ ] i'm trying to tell fresh
i'm like you're fresh you make [ __ ]
look at you like you a rookie now like
[ __ ] you you're supposed to be a whole
pro you supposed to be giving game now
[ __ ] looking at you like bruh if you
don't even get that [ __ ] how the [ __ ]
[ __ ] if you don't understand a pickle
roll how the [ __ ] you gonna teach them
about the triangular office [ __ ] [ __ ]
you talking about
phil jackson
yo yo yo wait let me say this let me say
this bruh nobody go to her
family that's hold up man he calling
back yeah yeah but you can get you can
get clap for that bro so don't do some
[ __ ] like that
[Music]
no
fresh i'm telling you brother listen
i'm only pointing it out
i know you like her
and by the way i've been trying to tell
you it's cool to just pull the
i'm gonna lie you got points but i like
her and and and i'm willing to take the
chance bro that's that's all possible
[ __ ] i've i've said it before
boom chat [ __ ] everybody was it wasn't
rocking with angelica i like angelica i
loved angelica and i took mad chances to
try to be with her at the center you
feel me bro you don't have to appease an
audience that's i've always said that
but
the only thing is that's what i keep
telling you is like [ __ ] a lot of when
you just co-signing anything she's
saying
it makes what you normally say on a
podcast look like cap
because it's like wait you ain't gonna
call her about calling out about that
so when you're on the podcast they
blamed the reddit
damn okay they're fresh and fit read it
channel
everything yeah if you shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] like
yo girl do that like you ain't saying
nothing about it why the [ __ ] you want
to say about somebody else
that's what i'm telling you though
she got caught she first said she [ __ ]
would you mind what you don't call out
[ __ ] why the [ __ ] y'all seeking
arrangements in the get-go
[ __ ]
yo a chick yo fresh you gotta keep it a
hunting a chicken seeking arrangements
there is game by the way i agree with
myron i agree with you you could go get
some girl off seeking arrangements but
you know that straight [ __ ] because she
got an object and you she got an
objective and you got objective her
objective is trying to finesse you your
objective is the bigger objective is to
finesse her and just get the [ __ ]
know i've been doing this for [ __ ]
right i know you've been doing this for
years but you ain't feeling loving years
[ __ ] you fell in love now
don't see anything on reddit about fresh
and food
french this is fresh this is where it's
capped this is where it's cap
fresh this is cap you will not you will
not i should make a manosphere drama
channel like you know how they have like
like youtube and like
like bachelorette and like all those
trauma channels there's not one in the
manosphere
i
have to think about this idea do you
like the idea let me know in the chat
say to her when she was in the car [ __ ]
when i i was manning up and saying [ __ ]
you gotta share that [ __ ] now you see
what you what type of time you want if
you want to be around you gotta share
that [ __ ] you were silent now she
hopped out the car ran oh my god i'm
gonna cry [ __ ] you saying all this [ __ ]
now why are you saying what you in the
car
i said on live everything you just told
me to say i slipped her life already so
so you looked at her and said shorty you
guys share me
yes [ __ ] watch your life bro
you're gonna have to share me
um
i said yo you need to go home i had a
girl look
i i'm still banging other girls bro it's
not like oh i'm only [ __ ] here bro
i'm bringing other girls bro she knows
she has to share me that being said bro
i like to know shorty she's cool i love
working she's cool that being said look
do like everything else out the window
like she's cool people no i'm not gonna
wait for her as my wife no [ __ ] i know
one i never get mine again two at all
kids so me i'm just having fun bro that
being said that's another girl wait let
me go back
uh 20
just cap this cap
fresh this is cap you will not you will
not say to her when she was in the car
[ __ ]
when i i was manning up and saying [ __ ]
you gotta share that [ __ ] now you see
what you what type of time you want if
you want to be around you gotta share
that [ __ ] you were silent
now she hopped out the car ran oh my god
i'm gonna cry [ __ ] you saying all this
[ __ ] now why you say what you in the car
i said on live everything you just told
me to say i said during life already so
so you looked at her and said shorty you
go out and share me
yes [ __ ] watch your life bro
i said yo you need to go home i had a
girl look i i'm still banging other
girls bro it's not like oh i want a
[ __ ] hair bro i'm making other girls
bro she knows she has to share me that
being said bro i like to know shorty
she's cool i like violent work she's
cool that being said dude like
everything else out the window like
she's cool people no i'm not gonna wait
for my wife no [ __ ] i know one i never
get mine again two i don't want kids
okay so he's not getting married he
doesn't want a kid this isn't his wife
okay i'm just having fun bro that being
said i'm telling all the girls so to me
it's cool i don't really care
yo yo fresh fresh
i agree with you so so now you're
talking my language but
i've yet to see you say that to her
maybe i ain't seen it
i was hold on you're fresh i was
throwing you the alley-oop when she was
sitting right next to you and i was
telling her the game
i was telling her well you should tell
her you know why because when you're on
the show and you're with them quote
three of foes you tell him the game so
i'm kicking the game to her except you
kept quiet cause really you don't want
to [ __ ] up the love of your life you
don't want to tell her some [ __ ]
you were talking you were talking to her
so i didn't want to interrupt that's why
i didn't say anything so then y'all talk
i told on my stream look everyone saw my
stream yo
can someone let me know the time stamps
on his stream
of like when he told her
unless you're not sure he's like you're
like oh [ __ ] so i said i sent her
facebook many times that being said i
suppose her behind the scenes is what it
is it's constant bro dude she cleans my
crib bro she wants my dog she's really
whatever say yo could you open this up
you're fresh every girl would do that
[ __ ]
no no hold on
yeah you're cleaning a crib
yeah yeah
you're fresh you don't gotta you're
fresh you're fresh i got a i got a 8 000
square foot home you know how big that
is
8 000. no no no you know 8 000. you you
don't clean my crib you don't clean my
crib the latest the latest chick that
comes over the [ __ ] because i'm not
getting no made if you're here
as a part of rotation right if someone
can do it for you but they're annoying
as [ __ ] she happens to be one that's
just chill doesn't talk a lot shut the
[ __ ] up that's what i like a lot that
being said bro other girls yeah they
could do the same thing but
they [ __ ] annoy me so this is yo
fresh you can't have her as the face
card she doesn't [ __ ] the [ __ ] she
[ __ ] a [ __ ] the same week she met you
[ __ ] you can't okay and face card that
means like the main like the girl you
take out in public associate with i have
that she said it on the podcast all
right you know what dean said things
said
she's with somebody before me
not the same week so she met him months
ago
dude think about this right are you
justifying this
is [ __ ] somebody
when she [ __ ] me
off yo
if if my [ __ ] is [ __ ] a [ __ ] yo if
i meet a chick and a [ __ ] in the room
no you should [ __ ] i'm good
she [ __ ] [ __ ] in the room not just a
[ __ ] though
it's a [ __ ] 304 there's a girl
i don't care if she's not sick it's just
not bro i'm just having fun
girls you associate with me
good for her bro hold on fresh could you
now admit
that she never liked you for you she
likes you for the bag
[Music]
no just answer the question you guys a
hack
you will not me you know why you won't
admit that cause you in love my brother
[Music]
yo
yo same with me hold on no same with me
no no same with me same with me but it
doesn't it doesn't mean that they want
you for you
not because they don't get what they
want mean they want you for you
doing my thing
she is literally doing whatever i say i
don't give a [ __ ] and she's still there
this is multiple girls bro you gotta
start right i absolutely like it because
she doesn't talk a lot she does what i
say she's very submissive i don't know i
don't i don't know what she's about to
do but she's doing what i want to do
when i'm done with it i'm done with it i
look i gotta check over every other
night it doesn't really matter so it's
like i saw my phone she's gonna pass bro
to me do you guys worried about stds or
does that just not
[Music]
the right question so why are you
showing her off like she's your face
card [ __ ]
hold on yeah you know what you're
admitting right that's what i was saying
there's a difference like
between the way he treats her and the
way he treats the other girls
she for the screech [ __ ] that's what
you say that's what you meant right yeah
if y'all both having fun oh
you're having fun she's for the streets
right
yeah i know okay so why she your face
card [ __ ] yo hold on yo yo french
you're fresh you fur hold on let me make
one point you're fresh you know when
they try to mention me and selena i said
[ __ ] though i never dated her [ __ ] out
of here you know what
she can't be my face card [ __ ] she
[ __ ] is sucking everybody yo girl
[ __ ] is sucking everybody in miami
that's not my girl dude that's what was
she a face car [ __ ] face card though
[ __ ] my first card is everything a girl
no [ __ ] you got her on
stream like that
[ __ ] i watched out on a vlog every 23
seconds you put your hand around her
like you bout to put her in a [ __ ]
chokehold and you try to kiss a [ __ ]
that's a face
what did card tell you off camera that
i'm doing
the marketing i'm doing what i take off
camera nothing [ __ ] the [ __ ] what the
hell i don't like i don't like no no no
tell me huh
i want to do the ddg
i want wanna see
[ __ ] the ddg right won't work for you i
keep telling you that you know why
because it's the ddg route i don't
ddg
is actually a lover boy
you and myron preach being hard on
thoughts i know about being hard on
thoughts you can't wife a chick who
talking like that i'm telling you you
gotta [ __ ] her
know her face
and send her on her [ __ ] way
when i say
the ddg wrote
i'm also trolling okay
i'm also trolling doing something that
no other arbitrary content creator is
doing
except you're doing it the worst way
you're you're you're yo you're i keep
telling you this you're you're trading
100 to get 10. yo your entire your
entire audience base that listen to you
for years is looking at you to say this
doesn't match why is he operating with
the chick who's eight she's not even a
304 [ __ ] she might be a 103 [ __ ] she's
just not that type of chick
and you over here is pressed doing the
most for her she can't compete brother
she making you look like the clown you
might as well put her
put some makeup on and put a red nose
she make you look like you stupid but
you were boss that's what i was trying
to tell [ __ ] i told you this from the
get-go [ __ ] if you won't be around her
[ __ ] she should be feeding you grapes
she not feeding feeling grapes she's
talking [ __ ] she looking at you and
talking to you like she enterprise
she's a seeking arrangements check
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] off camera
if i put on camera bro
[ __ ] be
so why would you put this [ __ ] on camera
that's embarrassing to you
mm-hmm
cause i'm trolling [ __ ]
you're trolling okay
oh hell no
yo yo it's like a gangsta rapper
because i was trolling what [ __ ] it
goes against everything you stand for
that's not trolling
okay wait let's let's see the dates on
this so this was
november so this was yesterday and was
this before or after the album preach
video
um so this is november 23rd
dang i wish i knew the dates or the
times because i think that's actually
important
but it just says the dates this was the
same day okay
bro
bro you know it's funny
this whole situation
yo
be funny bro no i'm serious yo yo yo
french i'm telling you [ __ ] i'm so
serious you're fresh fred fresh fresh yo
on some realistic level bruh on some
realistic level my [ __ ] you see you see
today
today is a great day for fresh and fit
[ __ ] us myron just went [ __ ] viral
for violating some chick bro bro you
can't be the [ __ ] who go now sad [ __ ]
that's why i kept telling you choose
your podcast over a [ __ ] relationship
[ __ ] that relationship [ __ ] she [ __ ]
old [ __ ] anyway pick your podcast pick
bruh like [ __ ]
take your poison bruh
[ __ ] nobody believe that but like three
kids bro stop it bro [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know what people are looking at
yo this [ __ ] is supposed to be hitting
this chick actively with the game of
shorty
you gotta share me i'm a high value man
you are living in your car shut the [ __ ]
up and let me be me oh my god
they're rude oh my goodness i would not
like instead all we see is you giggling
[ __ ] you look like me you look like a
[ __ ] chipmunk we always see your
[ __ ] cheeks while you hugging on her
trying to kiss her no [ __ ] they want to
see you be a boss they want to see you
be that [ __ ] who'll be giving game but
they see you trying to get smooches and
she curving you nobody wanna see that
i'm telling you your audience don't
wanna see that you always wanna see you
be a boss they wanna see fresh ceo they
wanna see you with a lambo with ten
[ __ ] stuffed in it like a clown car
that should be a [ __ ] by the tire wheel
that should be bitched by the [ __ ]
trunk there should be three [ __ ] in
the front box passenger seat there
should be eight [ __ ] in a goddamn
back there shouldn't be miranda who's
who's on her phone who's texting a bunch
of [ __ ] on seeking arrangements who
are 65 who she could probably get a
hundred and fifty dollars from that she
about to suck that [ __ ]
that's not how a chick should treat a
[ __ ] like you who's a high value man
that's all i'm saying brother that's all
i'm saying could i get a testimony in
chat please
talk to me have you seen my vlogs yo can
we get a i have a manager okay so
multiple girls right
no [ __ ] you look like you're in love
with her
bro
i [ __ ] the spanish girl the same day
picture i [ __ ] her
[ __ ] you should have all these chicks
to get yo yo i'mma be honest with you
you should need to give her the
intention of even being with you alone
you shouldn't your money i'm telling you
you shouldn't give her the intention of
being with you alone
i have a vlog that says spanish girl or
a white girl hey that was wifey i ain't
[ __ ]
yeah
you're fresh fred fresh
i know you think you'd be kicking
knowledge fresh but fresh we could see
through you yo yo fresh you are so situ
fresh fresh
your type is
white caucasian women from the caucasus
the corkazoid mountains okay that
spanish girls you were [ __ ] you was
never so googly eyed about this chick
miranda when she talks you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you usually stutter you started 30 times
when she talk
like you can't even talk [ __ ]
this is how i know damn
damn
dad you're trying to put off for the
chat continue right now bro right
if you knew
my past i married what a latina woman
bro white room for me bro
they are birth control they cool to
chill with and i [ __ ] with it that's
gonna go on my weakness
you're fresh you're fresh yo you're
fresh you got to keep it real with
yourself it's not even me so fresh are
you trying to [ __ ] i literally [ __ ] i
literally i lit
i literally
heard you say on a instagram or whatever
youtube live stream with her right next
to you you said you're tired of [ __ ]
mad [ __ ] and you're down to sell down
i heard you monica so again you didn't
say about you didn't say that when you
were [ __ ] them spanish [ __ ] you
only said that when you got a chick from
the corkazoid mountains that you could
feel that you could say hey this is what
i want brother
i'll play the footage right
girl that i'm now into i can if i want
to just be with her that doesn't mean
that is miranda it doesn't mean it's
melinda it doesn't mean it's jackie that
doesn't mean it's
matilda
the point is that like bro
i can do one girl but i don't choose to
that's the whole point i don't choose to
right now so
what's the argument here yo yo you're
fresh fresh
this is where you be going wrong
because you see when you like a girl
myra needs to give a fresher company
discount on a coaching session keep it
real
i'm just curious what does it cost
to okay wait
i'm sure fresh and fit has like a
website
um
okay so let's just go to their youtube
channel how much if i wanted to get like
a coaching session how much does that
cost okay wait
um it's gotta be in the description
right
ladies dms on demand clips channel
twitch free ebook
purchase our merch okay one-on-one
coaching so if i wanted to get coaching
from fresh that would be
um
so if i wanted to get a coaching session
from oh my god a thousand dollars
for one hour is that for all of them
oh my god
i'm pretty sure that's what kevin
samuels charges
okay so what about
fit
10 minute
oh i guess he's a little less 900 jesus
oh my god
that is wild i really think some way
around her because you want to please
her
fresh i'm telling you i could pull up
the video and you didn't say this just
to me you said this to your entire
audience
i am tired of [ __ ] [ __ ] i want to
settle down that's what you said [ __ ]
you literally said you want to keep it
between you and her because you were
[ __ ] bad [ __ ] but you were ready
for you and her you ain't telling no
other girl that but her don't switch it
up now my [ __ ] not not that we found
out that she don't seek an arrangement
selling the [ __ ] for
115 bucks there's nothing wrong with
that just admit it that's who you want
to be with
it's not bro
if it really was right bro you think i
would even ask this phone call for the
roadster
this is one thing you guys realize about
me
i'm a straight demon like so it's it
like to keep it real i like you i'm
gonna give you credit you the only [ __ ]
would even answer this phone call
because any [ __ ] would realize act is
about to demolish this chick and if i
like her like i'm gonna be honest with
you she gonna probably beat your ass
later you know why
if you really liked her you would never
put her on the phone with me [ __ ] i'm
going to eat her alive
i'm going to tell you why this phone
call happened because in reality you you
acting like you knew about all this [ __ ]
but in reality you really don't know how
deep it goes so you need a [ __ ] like me
you need a [ __ ] like me to figure it
out because you really don't know how we
go
yo fresh you would not be on the podcast
tomorrow i met her on a yacht knowing
all this [ __ ] cause
you know how in all this [ __ ] i think i
said that [ __ ] on life the [ __ ] dean
the jamaican guy showed me the whole
history bro i already knew
what you were doing
if that was the truth you refresh it
if that was the truth you would never
ever say she likes me for me you would
never say that
no
she does she does what oh
french friend for you
that's not real first please stop bro
stop
she will post screenshots of her cats
have to end fresh's
it careers fresh feel fresh not because
she didn't get anything from you now
means that's all she wants from me i
could dm her i wonder if she would i'm
gonna dm her
oh damn she can does not get except dms
from people that don't follow her let me
try her
my [ __ ] is called playing the law game
see if she'll call into this live that
would be interesting probably won't but
ask me bro
all right
all right so let me ask you a question
all right okay all right
no no i i hear what you're saying no i
hear what you say okay
valid point no no no no no no no no no
no
tell me please tell me no
okay okay
said yo i'm reacting live right now to
them slandering you i'm gonna send her
the link
um
[Music]
and then let's do a
i doubt she'll respond but you never
know do a little copy and paste
let me know
let me know
if you want to call in
and give your side of stuff
you know
i don't
i don't really care but
it would be somewhat interesting
yeah fresh fresh i'm agreeing with you
i'm agreeing with you but i'm asking a
counter question okay so i so i agree
with that so now
so so now i'm asking you the question
why do you think she wants you
so she doesn't want you for money i
agree with you with that why does she
want you
giving her history why she wants you
they say she's living off his wallet why
not tell me why someone what he's doing
that's good she has a fun time that's it
it's the experience i have to i have to
flip it differently i can unsend it and
resend something else
you're the only [ __ ] in miami that
could ever ever get a fun time so you
tell me that when she was seeking
arrangements and all these [ __ ] own
yachts boats private jets
all type of [ __ ] that could make her
have a good time she don't have fun with
them she only have fun with you
bro
[Music]
the connection we have
is one
we're just having fun is lit and two
there's no pressure like it's kind of
like okay
so why can't she have that with another
dude though
because she
stuck on me bro like dude how do you
know hold on how do you know we just
watched tick tock she's giving a
tutorial how to get new [ __ ]
that's a leo go to club of your friends
go through your [ __ ] i'm i'm right i'm
going to stay home i want to be with you
yo
go go have your friends i want to be
with you wait that's it wait wait hold
on
you're fresh you never heard you never
heard a woman lying
no way
i
literally
give her multiple things to do
away from me
and to her other people to die that's
what given you look even if it was a
finesse or something
yeah fresh
she's not my girl so it don't matter
yeah
can i ask you one question
okay go ahead and i'm going off for what
you just said
let's just say her goal was to get money
but clearly you're not giving it up
right
yeah however you say to her hey you
could go and have a great time or
whoever
right remember her goal is to get money
from you maybe not now maybe in a year
maybe two years maybe five years maybe
she wants to just get pregnant who knows
right
let me ask you this question
if her goal is to get money from you
and you told her no go out and have fun
would she go out and have fun and go
[ __ ] some other [ __ ]
well i told her no no yes or no you got
you gotta ask the question
you gotta answer the question would she
go out and have fun by [ __ ] a [ __ ]
or jeopardizing whatever she has with
you
no
okay okay
so your answer you know
yeah pearl flip it different tell her
something like okay wait i can
let me unsend the last
one
okay i'll i'll put it i don't
hi
i'm pearl
covering their recent
events
on
um
and fresh and fit
on my live
right now
um
do you want to give
your side of the story
your i'll say your side of things
um hey hey get out
my dog keeps trying to go through my
trash
um do you want to give your side of
things
should i send her my number
that'd be a bold move i'm gonna do it
i'm gonna do it
if you oh wait i'm in the uk
i'll say if you do comma
text me
because i can still get imessage and
facetime
at eight
oh my god i'm not about to say my number
on this live
you said she could have but why was she
let me ask you why was she
[ __ ] i got her [ __ ]
[ __ ] what you mean [ __ ] what do you
mean
[ __ ] you think you think you about to
give her a fatality
[Music]
or should i just respond to my dm
or
fresh is a month in
yo you're fresh forever
hold on i'm i'm giving you game because
i i was with i was gonna inject hold on
i was with angelica i was with angelica
i was with angelica for four or five
years i was with angelica for four or
five years and i could admit probably to
hold on that i've i loved her
she never asked for a [ __ ]
thing in the first year she never asked
for [ __ ] if you think that okay who is
angelica girl's gonna answer something
in the first month only a [ __ ] idiot
would do that [ __ ] she gonna play the
long game
that's considering it's gonna last that
long [ __ ] last three months four months
[ __ ] she could look at your eyes and
tell that you don't want to leave her
bro
i literally left her dude okay hold on
they're not straight they're not going
to show you a badass french girl right
big ass big titties
that came to the crib they did not
while you were here [ __ ] that was
before she was she was in the picture
brother
no it's not [ __ ] no what's up bro
yeah first fresh also also i'm gonna
tell you this don't [ __ ] up your own
situation cause you're the one who love
not me
if i wasn't gonna do it this book i want
what i'm doing right now you don't hurt
that way bro oh [ __ ] [ __ ] up think about
it think about it you think she'll look
at me the same way after getting with
that [ __ ] and [ __ ] from in front of
me [ __ ] should be [ __ ] up so no [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] you gotta tell her like yo
listen man
yo she got red flags you ever seen that
meme red flags [ __ ] you want seeking
arrangements and you told me you know
you're not with me for the money red
flag [ __ ] you talking about your
personality chicks but i've seen you on
seeking arrangement tomorrow you only
like luxurious lifestyle red [ __ ]
flag
those girls request a bag do 50 push-ups
i can't even do five what the [ __ ]
up front if not they're [ __ ] with you
and if it's a long-term game guess what
i mean yo yo yo fresh i'm gonna see i'm
gonna ask you one question i'm gonna see
how delusional you are
okay are you willing to admit that she
was selling [ __ ]
bro
yes or no it says it all
she probably was 100 all it was
probably okay okay are you okay with
that
are you okay with that
[ __ ]
she's doing my girl one she's your face
card she's a face guard
no no no no no [ __ ] you keep bringing
on blogs on vlogs [ __ ] she's you're
kissing her every 20 seconds
[ __ ]
if she sucked at [ __ ] [ __ ] 15 minutes
before she get on a vlog with you [ __ ]
you don't care
[ __ ] she don't do that though exactly
because you are confident she's not
doing it cause she's your face card you
wouldn't kiss a girl if you didn't know
if she was doing that
[ __ ] she's working
she lives in a car
no no no no no
that was before okay all right i got
business business guy right behind the
scenes she's doing that [ __ ] literally
all day
and it comes after to do [ __ ] for me
like dude
i'm sorry bro i've got [ __ ] going on
[Music]
her pass is
so so you're you're okay okay see
this this is all your audience wanted to
hear she will never be your girl
no
no he's showing her off like his sister
bro bro i am literally telling you when
i bring her on you know what bring her
on his drama i guess she thinks she's my
girl wait how's it possible no way it's
controversy drama i do i
[Music]
i'm with you now i never heard you say
she will never be your girl because i
guarantee you she was in a car with you
right now you'd be saying everything and
kissing on her neck and like blowing
kisses to her you would never say that
but now that you have established that
you're saying that she's just a hoe that
you are [ __ ] because these [ __ ]
are for the screech
i get i understand what you're saying
shouldn't be a girl i get
it yeah i don't know let me ask you a
question
say my [ __ ] leave [ __ ] you want to be
mad right
bro
no no i'm saying if he did would you be
mad
dude bro
[Music]
oh
[Music]
and you gotta work in the track so you
don't give a [ __ ]
but see if i tell the picture sometimes
it's like bro you're gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] up
for me
oh my god yeah this is i think
where he lost her yeah that being said
she really knows
that like she's never gonna be my girl
but
she wants me and she's stuck like i got
her soul i do this with multiple girls
bro
oh my god
i need to do a reaction to this part
that is that's actually messed up
i look it
i know you guys are going to disagree
with me in the manosphere
i don't think it's cool
to try to steal girl souls as they call
it
and lead them on and make them think
it's something it's not um just like i
don't think it's cool
for women to lead men on and make them
think it's something it's not like i
don't think that's cool to brag about
um or do but you know whatever ah nah
okay yeah you're fresh this is the fresh
i'm used to okay i admit yeah
so so you basically you sold the
scallywag a [ __ ] dream let's go
that's what we wanted to hear
yes
[ __ ] i thought she saw your dream
bro no
[ __ ]
[ __ ] no no next week next next week
never right thanksgiving i'm in that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm just trying to tell you
you're not gonna be tight if my [ __ ]
leave [ __ ]
in front of you like like you know i
mean like everybody dip you know i mean
you gonna text your pull up on her and
just pipe her down i mean she was
sucking
like he could try
but i tell you she stuck
she stuck on you while you were there
but like when he hit her like when when
she dipped off yeah you're gonna pipe
right now
honestly you know what's funny
[ __ ] have choices at the podcast even
her mommy to like hit her up
to chill and [ __ ]
i see it
but once again she's not my girlfriend
yeah yeah i ain't gonna lie to you my
[ __ ] leaf hit me yo that [ __ ] got the
illest
don't snitch on him he got the illest
seeking arrangement profile for her
she gonna think this thing is a
billionaire
yo she gonna be sucking that yo she she
gonna think she goes
the way she's gonna be hype she gonna
think she's sucking that [ __ ] off on a
spaceship she just she's just sucking
that [ __ ] off in an uber
let's do a test
yeah
[ __ ] that'll be great let's do it
i'm [ __ ] serious bro i'm serious like
[ __ ] yo we got to put it yeah yeah yeah
yeah fresh
i'm with you we got to put these
scallywags to work i'm with you brother
that's what i'm doing right now bro
girls that work for me bro
all the phone calls
from my side
they handle all the paperwork they
handle all the spreadsheets they handle
bro i'm really just doing a podcast
network with [ __ ] and they weren't
from your buying scenes i don't want
cameras obviously
yo
that's legalized slavery i like it [ __ ]
oh my god
huh
i'm on twitch
[ __ ] you wanna do it oh player early
i'll show you after brother yeah bro
these [ __ ] girls [ __ ] hoes bro
like
yo just answer me one question
yeah
when this chick dumps you in the morning
please tell me you ain't gonna blame it
on me
[Laughter]
yo please yo fresh if you [ __ ] with me
please just say your act yo when she
dumps me in the morning this had nothing
to do with you
come on now my [ __ ] man
[ __ ] these scallywags
things from new york coming in poorly
booty out at this world bro coming this
weekend to see me bro what
where oh [ __ ]
your boy is good that's the toy bro you
can't pass me bro you know what time it
is dude do you think merrell would stick
with me i'm dealing with this [ __ ]
if you didn't know what it was by
disease
don't talk dude
i know we got a little tolerance but
hold on hey right bro
no [ __ ] seem to do the savagery bro
he's dude on camera obviously i'm nice
i'm chill but [ __ ]
the hoes don't say come on when i do the
[ __ ] bro
[Music]
gosh guys why didn't any of you tell me
that my camera came off
how long has it been like that
oh my god a whole minute
guys why any of you tell me this
you gotta let a girl know
is it back on
oh my goodness
let me
hold on
oh my gosh that's so irritating
okay well i'm gonna keep playing with it
just just out of precaution like i'm
gonna be honest with you i wouldn't [ __ ]
her because i feel like you got feelings
first i wouldn't do it i'm not the type
of guy like me i rock on my [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] no i would not now
would not don't know i would not do that
brother i would [ __ ] [ __ ] like i go a
lot like i feel like y'all got like soul
ties and love like [ __ ] hold wait hold
on [ __ ] wait
[ __ ]
look at this chick right here [ __ ] look
at her face [ __ ]
look at her face [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] your eyes just lit up [ __ ] now i
wouldn't do that chick you know why
cause you hate me you hate me i won't do
that to you
hey you can [ __ ] [ __ ]
i can't hate this bro
i can't no
what about this like if she down with it
would you run a train on her me you and
leaf
nah i don't do trains bro
[ __ ] i go first
you go second leaf goes third
i don't know
i don't wanna see another [ __ ] i can't
no no it's one after [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
seen each other dick [ __ ] it's one
after that time [ __ ] it's like we in
the weight room at a dentist it'd be
like all right
okay uh uh mr academics you're up next
let's be like yo
miss yo yeah is walter here you're next
what's up what's the problem
i feel like okay if we want to determine
do fashion fit actually have game
this would be my challenge to them
there has to be someone else there
that can verify they're not paying the
girls it's not girls already know not
hoes whatever
and they have to go to a bar and like
try to get the hottest like girl there
and they can't use their money or their
status
and even it'd be interesting if they had
like a pickup artist go with them to see
like who wins
i don't know just an idea
yo i can hold you i've been invited but
i just never did it bro
i i just
no bro
she down with that
she down with it
no no in general i've been invited to
like who trains but i never did it holy
[ __ ] she probably she's probably a
freak yo [ __ ] she was [ __ ] like 80
year old [ __ ] bro [ __ ] i seen the
they sent me the video you're one of the
[ __ ] who said they [ __ ] her
he said he [ __ ] he had to pop three
viagra's [ __ ]
one of these [ __ ] said they popped the
blue dolphin bro
that [ __ ] said he was going dummy in
the [ __ ] bro i'm like yo bro like like
you senile i don't even think i think
that [ __ ] was ejaculating like dust
like for real
something though
how tight is it like like did it feel
like the 80 year old [ __ ] was running
it's pretty sick
oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] was putting no damage
yes sir that's what i'm talking about
you
[Music]
[Music]
yeah just don't get finessed bro
yeah let me tell this bro i'm gonna keep
it honey with you
she should be a side chick [ __ ] you
pipe her out like whenever you want to
but like [ __ ] you could do what you
want [ __ ] the way she was kind of
moving it's like she was trying to make
you her [ __ ] bro you a high value man
look at the [ __ ] she talking about
like like she's trying to put a handcuff
on you she just wasn't you see what you
said i had to talk to i said yo bruh
my [ __ ] fresh gonna slang dick on you
when you want but when you want to go to
the club and [ __ ] some other [ __ ] you
either gonna be there and join in or
stay home and think about it facts
come on man
you had over here talking like like
[ __ ] she was moving like she was
running the program [ __ ] you gotta tell
her this is only one tv station over
this [ __ ] it's fresh tv station it's
only my program
you gotta tell that [ __ ] man
she got it though she got it [ __ ] you
gotta do you
i'ma make sure your [ __ ] i just listen
i know a lot of you
because i yo me i know i'm devious [ __ ]
if [ __ ] plays you out crazy [ __ ] outta
[ __ ] you would have hated me more than
you hate them
what's up nigga's name
uh eva eva and and peach like you the
ada you don't hate to be way more than
enemies cause me when i start clowning
this is a lot longer of a live stream
than i was expecting like i was not
expecting to watch this
[ __ ]
the jokes writing themselves i would be
like yo holy
oh [ __ ] now but you're good [ __ ] i just
couldn't have her play you out man and
the only thing i think she's a nice girl
by the way and by the way if you [ __ ]
like me what the [ __ ]
i don't think there's a moment
i only think
one thing you got to worry about or like
just be cautious about
[ __ ] she's very she's a sweet girl
and a lot of times that sweet girl [ __ ]
will
catch [ __ ] in that trap because she's
like oh you know funny she's lit she's
literally me and a girl for him let me
explain
she's so unassumingly
normal and cute you don't say come in
like who's been like you're so nice and
so calm i love that [ __ ] i'm a [ __ ]
demon bro like when i get a bit so bro
she does whatever i say like oh you're
so you're so nice
yeah yeah you're fresh i don't i don't
think you got her so though i'm gonna
keep it on it
i think she got it she got your soul no
i got so you know why why because she
she's doing for me
remember she hates man
[ __ ] no she bro i'm gonna keep it real
with you that girl oh yeah whatever you
think she doing for you bro i could tell
her from a mile away she one of them
white girls bro that get with a [ __ ]
and do the freaky [ __ ] that black girl's
gonna do [ __ ] she lick ass she suck
toes she do everything [ __ ] so whatever
she do to you that you're like oh my god
i got her she never done before she
sucked the [ __ ] she sucked the most
corns and bunions out of philly when it
came out of their [ __ ] goddamn
timberland boots out of them [ __ ] with
the beard who muslim i'm telling you out
of philly i'm telling you she's done it
all brother don't think she'll do to you
brother she has been doing the most she
been sucking cars and bunions for
goddamn 10 years trust me i'm telling
you i mean
look better outside like [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] white she can't [ __ ] cook
bro she lived in a car what you mean the
hours she put in she got no job it's not
like she got a life
[ __ ] she she dropped out of stu school
to move to florida [ __ ] she got a
[ __ ] life
she got a job bro
she got a job
[ __ ] her job is sucky old dick
[ __ ] out yeah yo yo fresh you'll be
thinking like i'm a fool [ __ ] i checked
out the app that app [ __ ] [ __ ] her
job is sucking your [ __ ] [ __ ]
terrible terrible see you finally
keeping it real
keep it real i gotta turn the big
soldier on you gosh oh man what you
talking about to my some [ __ ] app
[ __ ] you know her app is her app is
fresh ce oh [ __ ] that's her app [ __ ] is
you talking about [ __ ] how you got
these scallywags acting like you not the
prize
fresh what are you doing
fresh these scallywags gotta realize
you're the price
they're replaceable stay with me you're
the prize
they're replaceable
remember
my strategy is a little different
because
this is the one thing i just agree with
um
like these shows on you don't think a
girl as hot as her can replace fresh in
like two seconds with another guy just
as rich and successful as him
sorry
[ __ ] she was living in her car you
don't need no [ __ ] strategy for that
tell that chick either she get down or
go homeless that's it get down go
homeless get down go homeless you don't
need no strategy with a chick who don't
even got a roof over her head
she can't pay rent she better suck [ __ ]
facts you can't pay rent you better suck
[ __ ] that's it what are we talking about
what are you talking about right now
what are you talking about
okay so thinking
no money for me right so like
i'll do it in a way that's like okay
if i will be cool
but you gonna do what i say [ __ ] you
had it yo yo [ __ ] you had you had a 14
month lease on that [ __ ] before she
start asking for [ __ ] that's what's your
company like baby you know i love you
and everything but like i can't spend as
much time with you as you normally would
have me do because i got to go to work
now because i can't afford this you know
what you're going to say i'm beat us you
know what you're going to say
baby like yo i'd rather you just sit
here and suck my dick whenever i want to
so yo i i i i'll help out a little bit
bruh
she's supposed to do that brush she's
not trying to get no [ __ ] job my
[ __ ] [ __ ] she nuts bro she is not
trying to work her job is to suck
penis i'm sorry brother
remember right i told you i've been a
ticket for for years right bro so the
moment that comes up
oh damn it
that's what i tell you you got a 12
month you got a 14 month lease so you're
gonna beat that [ __ ] down just make
sure i don't know about your pull out
gaming
the way you were looking at her that
that [ __ ] look like he might be weak
pearl secretly wants massive shoulders i
don't get it
hold on fresh keep it real with you keep
it real with me like just keep a room
you've been nothing right that's a fact
you've been nuttin inside of her
what do you think of course [ __ ]
what do you think of course
[ __ ] i know that [ __ ] yo when you
nothing a [ __ ] bro
it's it it's like it's weakness [ __ ]
i'm telling you like your knees don't
really like buckle away [ __ ] [ __ ] like
it's weakness
you've been nuttin [ __ ] you let me tell
this yo let me tell you it remind me of
when i was dealing with this white girl
in college [ __ ] i was f i know a lot of
you i lived in a whole apartment and i
moved into a dorm think about this i
lived in the whole apartment and i moved
into her dorm [ __ ] like you know them
bomb ass things that moving with their
ps4 and jordan's i moved in there you
know why [ __ ] i didn't see my [ __ ] for
six to eight months [ __ ] i don't know
where it went i don't know what happened
to it but i never seen a [ __ ] i was not
in that chick like it was going out of
style i kid you not that's what you're
doing i don't think she can replace
fresh with a guy that will spend this
much time with her
okay
you would be surprised
because white girls are always on
breakfast
white girls they be keeping their birth
control up except you better hope she
ain't children but
i don't like you [ __ ] with her so you
you're not even thinking about that it's
your brother's role
yeah
bro
i was there when her mom called me she
was on it bro
she was funny
ellie
yo you know what i mean right
her mom's just trying to make sure like
yo hey baby have fun with them negroes
but don't get pregnant by one of them
negroes
okay i don't want no kids right now
essentially
[ __ ] you probably dumped at least like
300 nuts inside of her bro
[ __ ] two to three [ __ ] [ __ ] yo i'm
gonna keep it real with you though first
oh my god you guys are irresponsible
that is so irresponsible
how are they that old how are you that
old and still doing that
you're gonna
trust a girl you've known a month
oh that is irresponsible
and you better not be mad at me
you know she's not giving me no more
[ __ ] after this
huh
i don't know if it's a joke but [ __ ]
just don't blame me
no no she's going to shoot him over
20 minutes bro oh okay no no no she's
coming over to argue
i don't know y'all french you're
supposed to be the guru [ __ ] but you're
sorry listen she coming over to argue
with you about everything you done said
on this [ __ ] because she listening mad
as [ __ ]
because you've been lying to her [ __ ]
all right
i got a sword bro see
this is where
[ __ ] need to get to
i can say anything you can say anything
so you could say you want to [ __ ]
another [ __ ] tomorrow and she gonna be
i mean she's gonna be mad of course
[ __ ] but like she know what time it is
what
she goes
whenever i wanted to
oh
oh i would have paid oh my god i would
have paid to see this conversation in
real life
oh my god
you're fresh i know a lot of you i'm
glad you put her on the track bro
guess what
put her to work man put her ass on the
[ __ ] hey hold on and i'm gonna keep
it real it's gonna turn out good for you
know why cause she on that [ __ ]
on that [ __ ] tick tock talking crazy
but you got her on the track working for
you that's a boss move
[ __ ]
hold on
[ __ ] man
[ __ ] metal for this [ __ ] bro
for too long bro
okay you know i'm [ __ ] up right bro
like i let me i think mario talking
because definitely he's more articulate
i just sit back chill check me here
more articulate but you got the game
bro there's a reason why my myron
respects me because he's seen the bro
mostly
like for example
all the students that came to the boot
camp that we had in miami damn they seen
it in real time multiple girls serving
me
yo [ __ ] that what's your rank her head
game at though
um
she white she better have an eight or
nine or a
i'm glad you met you had a better score
to hurt bro what a hell nah
the porn star yeah
geez
i would
i would think that a porn star like
better have the best damn head game out
of all of them yeah porn star was way
better bro then y'all get some lip
fillers or something all right hold on
baby
wait the head game weak week
i've been coaching
but
i'm going to take off
hold on oh you know you got to teach
another i see you you got to train them
sometimes you got to be like yo listen
you gotta like literally tell them like
step by step
yo grab this with your both hands
put it in this
you know cuban link chain where you
gonna shoot and link your hand around
this [ __ ] dick now you know what i
mean you gotta tell we gotta let them
know
[Music]
don't tell me that melody got a better
[ __ ] but please don't no
bro
i can hold you
like this
[ __ ] strippers
[ __ ] if her pussy's trash [ __ ] i don't
even know why you got to tell me why you
were with her
because because
these girls bro
have [ __ ] experience
and some of these goodies
they're [ __ ] like
starfishing back bro it's like actually
bro
what do you rank her [ __ ] on one of ten
um
a mirror whatever her name is
[ __ ] it look like you wanna join us
where like you gotta focus like you're
taking a math a math exam to come like
like you know
yo you been [ __ ] a girl and she was
like yo you wait when you gonna come and
you like your [ __ ] i gotta think about
this [ __ ] yo [ __ ] is mid
it's pretty good but it's just like
uh it ain't that way i could i could
tell like like she's hershey don't look
too moist you feel me it all looked too
you know what i mean
i don't like that
it ain't got that gushy gucci i feel it
brother hold on wait
no way melody [ __ ] is more wet than hers
no way no [ __ ]
that was a violation man
holy
holy
get to the information over here brother
[ __ ] no you
you free rocks and hit your hand
no [ __ ] i ain't had no [ __ ] hand
[ __ ] she's [ __ ] she's sucking [ __ ] on
goddamn seeking arrangements and hiding
her hands [ __ ] she's sucking caught no
hands why the hell you blaming me why
you don't blame her what's up with your
niece man blame her she'll be sucking
man cox are only fans oh goddamn all
these other apps why are you blaming me
for some [ __ ] she done that [ __ ] i'm
just talking about what she been doing
what's the problem
[ __ ] hate perk
yo queen what's cracking with you
ty track what up ty driving rocky oh my
god
um
okay if anyone wants insight
onto this situation
i would recommend that video i i feel
pretty much caught up
oh my gosh
let me look at that let me look at the
comments um
he's definitely obsessed with getting
girl souls it's sad after pulling all
these girls he still got played by her
he met on seeking
i guess i have to go with my final
thoughts now do i think he got played
um i think they kind of both played each
other like i think they both went into
it trying to play each other
um
and honestly after this conversation
like that is so humiliating if i was
that girl i would be so humiliated
um
yeah i'll put fresh on top for this one
to be honest as the winner
to because i
i'm sorry
that live stream was a thousand times
more humiliating for her
than abbott preaches video was for them
for him
now
don't get me wrong like
more people saw the abba and preach
thing
so there's that like you know pros and
cons here but like
i i
i would be humiliated
like humiliated
um
uh who stopped listening to the ignorant
dude
are we talking about the the video
oh my
gosh i feel like
there's a difference between like
watching this because i care
and watching this because
i feel like it's hot right now trending
um
i mean this is my
my my concept
fresh probably gets a good amount of
girls
because he's got like a blue check mark
he's got a big podcast makes a lot of
money like
yeah he can probably [ __ ] girls do i
think
he he's got the like
like game or whatever is
good enough to spend 800 on a dm course
and like a thousand dollars for
one-on-one coaching
no probably not
um
do do i think he is super butthurt over
this girl
no not really do i think he liked her
yeah
i think he'll probably be like bummed
probably like sad when she leaves for a
little bit but
he'll be fine um
and her i feel like she will be gone
and humiliated i would be so humiliated
if that happened to me oh my god that
live stream
was he getting girls a year ago i mean
okay let's do the math let me go back to
screen share let's do the math how old
is he let's let's start there anyone
know how old he is
so if he has a thousand girls that he's
had sex with
um anyone in the chat how old is he
anyone
um okay
and ceo
i love apple juice i'm so confused
um
there's no way he's 20. he looks way
older than that okay
um okay let's just go 30 okay
and was he faithful to his wife when he
was married to her
so let's say he started having sex at 16
so 26
27 28 29 30. so 14
years let's do a thousand divided by 14.
um
it's about 72
girls a year
so divide that by 12.
um
[Music]
so that's six girls
a month
wait so wait let me let me try that
again
so we're gonna take off
so if you started at 16 it would be six
girls a month minus a year so let's up
it to like eight girls so let's
sorry hold up
30
minus 16
minus a year so let's say he's been
having sex for 13 years
let's do a thousand
divided by 13
[Music]
76 per year
divide that by 12.
i actually i hate to say it guys
this is more believable than i thought
to be honest
um
i mean they don't have to be like you
don't think he could get like six fat
chicks
a month
like like let's just let's just be real
here were they tens
oh i might have just changed my mind on
this on the live
a thousand just sounds like such a big
number but then i like break it down and
i'm like huh
oh he admitted to losing his virginity
at 18. so let's go back to
the numbers
okay
um
so
29 minus 18.
and how long did he date the girl
um because
let's say he dated he married her for a
year but how long did he date her before
he married her
um
um
let's let's take off another year let's
say he dated her for a year
so nine years
a thousand
divided by nine
a hundred and eleven
divide that by
twelve
we got 10 girls a month
which would be about two girls a week
he got those bart bodies because he said
in barbados he would go out every night
and get one girl for each
night for three years straight because
he had a hook up with a dj or something
like that
huh
hmm
interesting it's actually more
believable than i thought it was gonna
be to be honest
h
i mean he probably i feel like all guys
cap
he paid
um okay i mean at the end of the day no
one's gonna know a thousand
i feel like he probably is capping but
now that i did the math on that that's a
little bit more believable
than i thought
like he never said they'd be good
looking but he could definitely get some
fat chicks to be honest
um
damn twos and threes
okay i'm ending this live though i'm so
tired
um
let me know in the comments if you like
these sort of live streams or if you
would have preferred a video
but yeah
i